Welcome to our second drink of New Boss.
Wow, a lot of you wrote in about this episode.
We got lots of mail.
We loved it.
Let's dig in.
Let's do it.
I'll start with Caitlin R. from Houston, Texas.
She wrote in to say,
欢迎来到我们第二杯《新老板》。哇，你们很多人写信来讨论这一集。我们收到了很多邮件。我们很喜欢。让我们深入探讨一下。开始吧。我先从德克萨斯州休斯顿的凯特琳·R开始。她写信说，
Hi, Angela, Jenna.
I love y'all's podcast so much and had a question about this episode.
This is one of my most favorite cold opens of all time,
and I wanted to know if any of the banter was improvised.
It makes me laugh so hard every time I watch,
every time I hear the word, classy.
I hear this whole conversation in my head. I love listening to y'all. Thank you so much.
Well, Caitlin, I love this cold open too. And to answer your question, it was completely scripted.
嗨，安吉拉，珍娜。我非常喜欢你们的播客，关于这一集有个问题。这是我个人最喜欢的开场白之一，我想知道其中的调侃是否是即兴发挥的。每次我看这一集，每次听到“优雅”（classy）这个词，我都会笑得不行。我脑海里一直回荡着这段对话。我很喜欢听你们的节目。非常感谢。嗯，凯特琳，我也很喜欢这个开场白。回答你的问题，它是完全照着剧本演的。
You guys, I'm going to remind you what the cold open is. It starts, and it's a party planning committee meeting.
And it is Jim, Dwight and Pam and Michael. And Dwight says, you know, Michael, since it's your 15th anniversary at the company, I thought it might be appropriate to begin the festivities with a 15-minute round of applause.
And then a 15-minute round of silence.
And, you know, Jim's in his tuxedo, because, of course, he's pranking Dwight.
And he's like, I don't know if this is classy enough.
Then it really goes off the rails, this party planning committee meeting.
So, Caitlin, we actually discussed this scene.
Plus, we have some extra dialogue that was in the shooting draft, and we talk all about it in our breakdown.
大家，我要提醒一下你们这个开场白是什么。它开始时是一场派对策划委员会会议。出席的有吉姆、德怀特、帕姆和迈克尔。德怀特说，你知道吗，迈克尔，既然是你入职公司15周年纪念日，我觉得用15分钟的掌声来开启庆祝活动可能比较合适。然后是15分钟的沉默。而且，你知道，吉姆穿着燕尾服，因为他当然是在恶作剧德怀特。他说，我不知道这是否足够“优雅”。然后这场派对策划委员会会议就彻底失控了。所以，凯特琳，我们确实讨论过这个场景。另外，我们还有一些拍摄草稿中额外的对话，我们在解析中都谈到了。
You're going to love it.
But I was curious if there were any extra bits that we might have missed.
And I saw in the table draft that this scene was even longer.
And Michael was really listing off all the types of things that he wanted for his, quote,
15th anniversary of working at Dunder Mifflin party.
And guess what, lady?
What?
There's this extra little tidbit that I thought you'd want to hear.
你们会喜欢的。但我很好奇是否还有我们可能错过的额外片段。我在剧本草稿中看到这个场景其实更长。迈克尔真的列举了他想要为他所谓的“邓德·米夫林工作15周年派对”准备的所有东西。猜猜怎么着，女士？什么？有个额外的小花絮，我觉得你会想听听。
We have always been curious.
What's the budget?
What is the party planning committee budget for these parties?
Yeah, to throw a party.
Right?
Yes.
Well, Jim had an extra couple of dialogue.
It made me laugh.
我们一直很好奇。预算是多少？这些派对的派对策划委员会预算是多少？是的，举办派对。对吧？是的。嗯，吉姆有一段额外的对话。这让我笑了。
Ready?
Jim would have said this.
I'm looking at your budget, Michael, and I think we're about $13,000 over the $200 corporate allotted.
So, do they get $200 for their parties?
I don't know, $200 for every birthday.
That seems a lot.
It kind of does.
But I don't know, you've got to get cake and pizza.
准备好了吗？吉姆本来会这么说。我在看你的预算，迈克尔，我觉得我们比公司分配的200美元预算超支了大约13000美元。所以，他们举办派对能得到200美元吗？我不知道，每次生日200美元。这看起来很多。确实有点多。但我不知道，你得买蛋糕和披萨。
But also, how many of those parties are actually sanctioned by corporate, right?
This is true.
Oh, my gosh.
Speaking of pizza, when I was in New York recently, I went to go see the new production of the Putnam County Spelling Bee.
It's such a funny show.
It's a musical.
Oh, my gosh, we laughed so hard.
My sister got picked to go up on stage.
但还有，这些派对中有多少是真正得到公司批准的，对吧？这是真的。天哪。说到披萨，我最近在纽约时，去看了《普特南县拼字比赛》的新制作。那是一场非常有趣的演出。是个音乐剧。天哪，我们笑得太厉害了。我妹妹被选中上台了。
It was like a whole fun thing.
And guess who was in it?
Who?
Kevin McHale.
Oh!
And he's so good in it.
But yes, Kevin McHale, who is the pizza guy that Michael takes hostage.
And launch party, part two.
那是一件非常有趣的事情。猜猜谁在里面？谁？凯文·麦克海尔。哦！他在里面演得真好。没错，凯文·麦克海尔，就是迈克尔在《发布会（下）》中劫持的那个披萨小哥。
Yes.
Yes, and it was so cool to reunite with him.
And I told him, we have to have you back on the podcast.
I know he sent in audio clips before, but I'm like, I want to talk to you more.
This is Office Lady 6.0.
People come in the studio now, guys.
That's right.
We've got a fancy, fancy recording studio.
是的。是的，能和他重聚真是太酷了。我告诉他，我们一定要请你再来上播客。我知道他之前发过音频片段，但我说，我想和你多聊聊。这是《办公室女士》6.0版。伙计们，现在人们都来演播室了。没错。我们有一个非常高级的录音室。
We were going to show it off.
All right.
Well, we also got this letter from Chantel P in Houston, Texas.
Chantel said, first of all, I'm too excited.
I had the wherewithal to enter this question ahead of
of the episode, exclamation point.
Chantelle, way to go.
I know, you're on top of it.
我们本来想炫耀一下的。好吧。嗯，我们还收到了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的尚特尔·P的这封信。尚特尔说，首先，我太兴奋了。我有先见之明，在这一集播出前就提交了这个问题，感叹号。尚特尔，干得好。我知道，你总是走在前面。
She goes on to say she loves the show, quote, I've been down since day one.
Okay, I wanted to know, Jen and Angela, in your perspective, what were the precipitating events
that led David Wallace to hiring Charles Minor?
Was it the fire drill and subsequent defacing of CPR Annie?
The dumpster fire that was the lecture circuit, the golden ticket idea, or a combo of them all.
I have to know.
What pushed David Wallace over the edge?
Well, this merely made me laugh.
她接着说她喜欢这个节目，引用道：“我从第一天起就一直支持。”好的，我想知道，珍娜和安吉拉，在你们看来，导致大卫·华莱士聘请查尔斯·迈纳的诱发事件是什么？是消防演习和随后的毁坏心肺复苏假人安妮吗？是作为讲座巡回赛的垃圾堆火灾，金奖券的想法，还是它们的综合体？我必须知道。是什么把大卫·华莱士逼到了边缘？嗯，这简直让我笑了。
I know, me too.
I mean, I think what precipitated it was that the job was open
because this is the job that Ryan had, that Jan had.
Right, that Jim didn't want.
Exactly.
And, you know, we had a whole hiring process,
and David Wallace picked Ryan,
and that blew up in his face.
我知道，我也是。我的意思是，我认为促成这件事的原因是这个职位空缺，因为这是瑞安曾经担任的职位，也是简曾经担任的职位。对吧，吉姆不想要的那个。没错。而且，你知道，我们经历了一整套招聘流程，大卫·华莱士选择了瑞安，结果搞砸了。
So I think that David Wallace is just finally filling this position.
I think he took his time.
It's very funny to me all of the things that happened when there was no one overseeing things.
And I also just love imagining Charles Minor getting kind of like caught up to speed on the Dundermifflin branch.
Let me tell you a few things.
Just because of all the things that Chantelle listed.
I know.
Like, what was that meeting like?
所以我认为大卫·华莱士只是终于在填补这个职位。我想他花了一些时间。在我看来，当没有人监督时发生的所有事情都非常有趣。而且我也很喜欢想象查尔斯·迈纳在邓德·米夫林分公司被“赶上进度”的样子。让我告诉你几件事。就因为尚特尔列出的所有事情。我知道。那场会议会是什么样子？
I know.
That would have been a great scene.
Wouldn't it?
Yeah.
Like, we're going to tell you a little bit about this branch before you head on over.
Well, I loved revisiting that. And I want to share with you one of my favorite letters from this second drink. It's from Susan F. from Kansas City, Missouri, said,
Hey, hey, ladies, just something I love about the podcast is when you point out a good Phyllis snark. One of my favorites is in this episode when she clearly is trying to take down the PPC.
Okay, Susan, so same here. I love Phyllis so much in our rewatch of the show. And we talked about the deleted talking head that she had, but we didn't,
我知道。那会是一个很棒的场景。不是吗？是的。就像，在你过去之前，我们要告诉你一点关于这个分公司的事情。嗯，我很喜欢重温那个场景。我想和你们分享我从这第二杯中选出的最喜欢的信件之一。它来自密苏里州堪萨斯城的苏珊·F，她说，嘿，嘿，女士们，关于播客我喜欢的一点是，当你们指出菲利斯精彩的讽刺时。我最喜欢的一处是在这一集中，她显然试图搞垮派对策划委员会。好的，苏珊，我也是。在重温这部剧时，我非常喜欢菲利斯。我们谈到了她被删掉的采访片段，但我们没有，
play the moment that made it into the actual broadcast. And Susan, I feel like we both need to hear it.
First of all, I pulled a clip, but I wanted to start with how absurd the PPC meeting is going on in
progress. We have already talked about it a little bit at the top with Caitlin's question. Now we're
going to hear it. And then Phyllis is setting them up. Ready?
And then out of that cake pops another stripper holding a smaller cake. And then an even smaller
stripper pops out of that one.
What is that smaller stripper holding?
A cupcake.
播放那个最终进入实际广播的时刻。苏珊，我觉得我们俩都需要听听。首先，我提取了一个片段，但我先从派对策划委员会会议正在进行的荒谬程度开始。我们在开头已经和凯特琳的问题一起讨论过一点了。现在我们要听听了。然后菲利斯在给他们设套。准备好了吗？然后从那个蛋糕里又跳出了一个脱衣舞娘，手里拿着一个更小的蛋糕。然后一个更小的脱衣舞娘从那个里面跳了出来。那个更小的脱衣舞娘手里拿着什么？一个纸杯蛋糕。
Nice.
It's cupcakes and strippers all the way down.
Okay.
What exactly is the PPC?
Oh, that's the party planning committee.
They spend hours planning parties.
Excuse me, guys.
What's going on in here?
不错。这简直是无穷无尽的纸杯蛋糕和脱衣舞娘。好的。派对策划委员会到底是什么？哦，那是派对策划委员会。他们花几个小时策划派对。打扰一下，伙计们。这里在发生什么？
Party planning committee, not your concern, Charles.
This doesn't seem like a good way to spend company time.
Really?
Well, then how would we come up with great ideas like gyms?
Like gyms. Go ahead.
No, I'd like to get back to work, actually.
What you got?
Jim?
派对策划委员会，这不关你的事，查尔斯。这看起来不是利用公司时间的好方法。真的吗？好吧，那我们怎么能想出像吉姆那样的好主意呢？像吉姆那样。继续。不，我其实想回去工作。你有什么？吉姆？
What is a two-way petting zoo?
My gosh, okay.
So I just have to ask you, lady, I mean, was it so hard not to laugh?
Because Idris Elba is playing it so straight.
Yes.
And he's like, what's a two-way petting zoo?
Like, it must have been so hard not to break.
It was really also very hard for me to say that line.
什么是双向宠物动物园？天哪，好吧。所以我不得不问你，女士，我的意思是，忍住不笑是不是很难？因为伊德里斯·艾尔巴演得太一本正经了。是的。他就像是，什么是双向宠物动物园？这一定很难不笑场。对我来说，说那句台词也非常困难。
It's just strippers and cakes.
all the way down. That is such a beautifully written line. It's, oh, chef's kiss to the writer who wrote
that. And then, yes, what is a two-way petting zoo? Yes, it was very hard not to laugh. It was.
And Phyllis, man, talk about just in the corner plotting, man. Yes. All right, well, listen, everyone,
we hope you enjoy your second drink of new boss. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together.
And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
这简直是无穷无尽的脱衣舞娘和蛋糕。那是一句写得非常漂亮的台词。哦，给写出那句台词的编剧点个赞。然后，是的，什么是双向宠物动物园？是的，忍住不笑真的很难。确实。还有菲利斯，天哪，说起她就在角落里密谋，天哪。是的。好吧，听着，大家，我们希望你们喜欢你们的第二杯《新老板》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies.
Good morning.
Good afternoon.
Good evening.
You did it.
You covered it all.
Did I get everybody?
每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你们的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。早上好。下午好。晚上好。你们做到了。你们涵盖了一切。我没漏掉谁吧？
You did.
This week we're talking about new boss.
I was delighted by this episode.
Me too.
I read the script. I read the script and I was cackling. Josh was like, what are you reading? I'm like,
it's the shooting draft for new boss. It was so good. This was season five, episode 20. It was written by
Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky and directed by Paul Feig. Hit me with a summary.
I will. There is a new boss at corporate. They filled the position that used to be held by Jan and then
你做到了。这周我们讨论的是《新老板》。这一集让我很高兴。我也是。我读了剧本。我读了剧本，我笑得前仰后合。乔什问，你在读什么？我说，这是《新老板》的拍摄草稿。太棒了。这是第五季第20集。由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，保罗·费格执导。给我一个总结。好的。公司来了一位新老板。他们填补了曾经由简和瑞安担任的职位，由新区域主管查尔斯·迈纳担任。他要来斯克兰顿访问。他要和我们所有人整天打成一片。是的。他还将宣布一些涉及我们预算的新政策，特别是我们的派对预算。好吧，公平地说，对于新老板，迈克尔本应该通知我们的。他本应该的。但再一次，他没有。相反，他开始策划他自己的15周年纪念派对。他在邓德·米夫林工作了15年，他想举办一个盛大的派对。盛大，盛大的派对。迈克尔和查尔斯，或者吉姆和查尔斯之间的事情进展得并不顺利。
Ryan with new regional supervisor Charles Minor. And he's coming to Scranton for a visit. He's going to hobnop with
us all day. Yeah. He is also going to announce some new policies involving our budget, in particular our
party budget. Well, to be fair to the new boss, Michael was supposed to let us know. He was.
But once again, he did not.
And instead, he started planning his own 15th anniversary party.
He's been working at Dunder Mifflin for 15 years and he wants to have a big party.
Big, big party.
Things do not go well with Michael and Charles or with Jim and Charles.
哦，那太有趣了。这可能是我有史以来最喜欢的连续情节之一。看着吉姆处于那种与某人疏远并感到尴尬的状态，真是太棒了。太，太有趣了。迈克尔快疯了。他试图给大卫·华莱士打电话。他打不通，所以他开车去了纽约，事情将在那里发生戏剧性的转折。速记事实第一条。我提到镇上来了一位新老板。哦，请给我角色解析。那个人是伊德里斯·艾尔巴。没错。好吧。是的，就是他。让我们把这件事解决掉。让我们卷起袖子谈谈伊德里斯一会儿。
Oh, that was so fun.
It's maybe one of my favorite runners ever.
Watching Jim be sort of like on the outs with someone and feeling like embarrassed was
So good. So, so fun. Michael is spinning out. He tries to get David Wallace on the phone. He can't, so he drives to New York, where things are going to take a dramatic turn.
Fast fact number one. I mentioned there's a new boss in town. Oh, please give me the character breakdown. That person is Idraselba.
Yep. All right. Yes, it is.
Let's get this out of the way.
Let's just roll up our sleeves and talk about Idris for a second.
伊德里斯是我见过最帅的男人。他是。我想说我见过一些绅士，著名的绅士。他不仅仅是帅。我不知道该怎么解释，伙计们。你知道那些走进房间，你只会说“该死”的人吗？这是一种整体的气场。是的，这是一种存在感。
Idris is the most beautiful man I have ever laid my eyes on.
He is.
And I want to say I've laid my eyes on some gentleman, famous gentleman.
He's not just beautiful.
There is just, I don't know how to explain it, you guys.
You know those people that walk in a room and you just go, damn.
It's a whole aura.
Yeah, it's a presence.
我们收到了来自安娜·B和阿里·C的粉丝提问，伊德里斯·艾尔巴是怎么加入这个节目的？兰迪告诉我，查尔斯·迈纳这个角色是为伊德里斯写的。他是他们唯一接触过的角色人选。他说伊德里斯的名字出现在这一集的剧情大纲里，这在大纲甚至在拍摄前两个月就出来了。他甚至发给我了，上面写着：内景，接待处，查尔斯·迈纳，逗号，伊德里斯进入。
We got a fan question from a.
Anna B and Ali C, how did Idris Elba end up on the show?
Randy told me that the role of Charles Minor was written for Idris.
He is the only person they ever approached for the role.
He said that Idris's name was in the story outline for this episode, which comes out like
two months before you even shoot it.
And he even sent it to me, it says, Interior Reception, Charles Minor,
comma, Idris enters.
就像，他们说，我们想要伊德里斯·艾尔巴担任这个角色。天哪，他们计划得这么远。是的。嗯，编剧团队是电视剧《火线》的超级粉丝。我正想说这个。我们有很多《火线》的粉丝。你还记得那个节目吗？每个人都对它着迷。那是一部很棒的剧。是的。能请到“斯特林格·贝尔”，来吧。我知道。嗯，他是我们请到的第二位来自《火线》的演员，因为艾米·瑞安也出演过《火线》。没错。我们收到了来自德里克·H的另一个粉丝提问，他说，我一直很好奇，对于那些在现实生活中有一种口音，但必须为角色说不同口音的演员，这是怎么运作的？伊德里斯·艾尔巴在拍摄间隙是说他正常的英国口音，还是全程保持角色的美国口音？
Like, they were like, we want to.
Idriselba for this role. Oh my gosh, they were planning this pretty far out. Yeah. Well, the writing staff
was a really huge fan of the TV show The Wire. That's what I was going to say. We had a lot of the Wire fans.
Do you remember that show? Everybody was so obsessed with it. It's such a great show. Yeah. And to get Stringer Bell,
come on. I know. Well, he's the second cast member we've had from The Wire because Amy Ryan was also on the
wire. Yep. We got another fan question from Derek H. who said, I've always wondered how it works.
with actors who have one accent in real life, but have to speak in a different accent for the role.
Did Idris Elba speak in his normal British accent between takes, or did he stay in character with his American accent the whole time?
是的，我想我们应该提到伊德里斯有英国口音。这几乎把我们所有人都击垮了。是的。我的意思是，如果你长得像伊德里斯，然后听起来又像伊德里斯，来吧。我们能做什么？我们也对他着迷。太着迷了。是的，他在拍摄间隙确实说他的英国口音。
Yeah, I guess we should mention Idris has a British accent.
Which pretty much wrecked us all.
Yeah.
I mean, if you look like Idris and then you sound like Idris, come.
What were we supposed to do?
We were also charmed by him.
So charmed.
And yes, he did speak in his British accent between takes.
好的。速记事实第二条。更多关于伊德里斯·艾尔巴的内容。好吧。我很抱歉。他太棒了。我们要继续谈论他。如你所知，自从出演《火线》和《办公室》以来，他已经去做了无数
Right.
Fast fact number two.
More Idris Elba.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
He's too great.
We're going to keep talking about him.
As you know, since being on the wire and the office, he has gone on to do a gazillion
事情，电影，电视节目。他最近出演了《自杀小队》。但你知道这个吗？因为我不知道。在他成为演员之前，他是一名DJ。好的，我知道那个。我知道那个，可能是因为他要来我太兴奋了。我查了他的一切。
things, movies, TV shows.
He was most recently in the suicide squad.
But did you know this?
because I didn't know this.
Before he was an actor, he was a DJ.
Okay, I did know that.
I did know that probably because I was so excited he was coming.
I looked up everything about him.
以防万一出现话题，我会知道一些东西。等等，在他上节目之前，你像谷歌搜索了他，然后你说，我需要谈话话题。我只是想知道关于他的一切。好的，直到我们必须为这个播客做准备时，我才谷歌搜索他，期间我发现他是一位大牌DJ。是的。成长过程中，他为派对做DJ。当他是一个挣扎的演员，第一次来到美国时，他很难找到工作，因为他有特殊的签证。
Just in case a topic came up, I would know something.
Wait, before he was on the show, you like Googled him and you're like, I need topics of conversation.
I just want to know everything about him.
Okay, I did not Google him until we had to prep for this.
podcast during which I found out that he is a big time DJ.
Yeah.
Growing up, he DJed parties.
And when he was a struggling actor, and he first came to the U.S., it was really hard for him to get work because he had a special visa.
但他能够以DJ的身份获得演出机会。他还做过保镖，我觉得这很有趣。他以“DJ大德里斯”的名字命名。现在他已经做了无数场演出。他为迈克尔·乔丹举办过派对。他为哈里王子和梅根·马克尔的婚礼做过DJ。那个我不知道。我怎么错过了那个？你需要多做点谷歌搜索。好吧，我想我需要重新谷歌一下。是的。他还在2019年参加了科切拉音乐节。他获得了好评，他刚刚通过他的厂牌“七华莱士”发行了一首新的浩室音乐曲目，叫《软糖》，由歌手伊丽莎·莱格齐纳演唱，我觉得我们应该听听。哦，我很乐意。这个男人不会做错任何事。他，我的意思是，停下来。我们能被邀请参加一个派对吗？
But he was able to get gigs as a DJ.
He also worked as a bouncer, which I found very interesting.
He goes by the name of DJ Big Driss.
And now he's done like tons of shows.
He did a party for Michael Jordan.
He DJed the wedding of Prince Harry and Megan Markle.
That I did not know. How did I miss that? You need to do more Googling. Well, I guess I need to re-google. Yeah. He also played Cachello in 2019. He got rave reviews and he just released a new house track through his label, Seven Wallace, called Fudge, with vocalist Eliza Legzina and I thought we should listen to it. Oh, I'd love that.
This man can do no wrong. He, I mean, stop it. Can we get invited to a party.
他做DJ的那个。那永远不会发生。我们可以吗？我不认为会发生。我不认为我们会进入名单，但我会很喜欢。你知道吗？我们可以。我们去躲在灌木丛里吧。我们溜进去。灌木丛躲藏者。灌木丛躲藏者去俱乐部。女士，这简直是我新的生活目标之一，那就是去参加一个伊德里斯做DJ的派对。我想去。然后跳舞。我们穿什么？你穿什么去那种地方？我可以戴我的一朵假花吗？我会说不，不要戴那个。我同意。我同意。
where he DJs. It'll never happen. Can we? I don't think it'll happen. I don't think we'll make the list,
but I would love it. You know what? We could. Let's go hide in some bushes. We'll sneak in.
Bush hiders. Bush hiders goes to the club. Lady, this is like kind of one of my new life
goals, which is to go to a party that Idris DJs. I want to do it. And dance it up. What do we wear?
What do you wear to something like that? Can I wear one of my fake flowers?
I'm going to say no, not on this.
I agree.
你知道伊德里斯出演的哪部剧是我丈夫最喜欢的吗？《路德》。是的。《路德》太棒了。太棒了。他还制作了一个他自己创作的节目，他在里面扮演一个叫“Turn Up Charlie”的DJ。他什么都做过。他什么都做过。好吧。
You know what show that Idris was in that my husband loved was Luther?
Yes.
Luther is so good.
It's so good.
He also did a show that he created himself where he plays a DJ called Turn Up Charlie.
He's done it all.
All right.
我会带我们继续。速记事实第三条不是关于伊德里斯的，尽管它可能是。速记事实第三条是，为什么这一集在下雨？整集都在下雨。整集。倾盆大雨。不仅仅是下雨，是倾盆大雨。以至于你在采访片段中都能听到雨声。
I will move us on.
Fast fact number three is not about Idris, even though it could be.
Fast fact number three is, why is it raining in this episode?
All throughout the episode.
The whole episode.
Pouring rain.
Not just raining, pouring rain.
So much so you can hear it in the talking heads.
是的。是的。我先查看了剧本。我想，有没有什么被删掉的内容告诉我们为什么下雨？我只发现迈克尔的一句随机评论。我也是。就在他和查尔斯闲聊的那个场景里。没错。
Yeah.
I started by looking in the script.
I thought, was there a deleted something that tells us why it's raining?
I only found one random side comment by Michael.
Same.
It's in the scene where he's making small talk with Charles.
Yep.
他说，天气真好，不是吗？有点下雨，你知道，但还是很潮湿。但仅此而已。就是这样。所以我问了兰迪，他是这么说的。他说，如果我没记错的话，我们进入这一周时，预计整个洛杉矶都会下雨。事实上，我们前两天拍摄的通告单顶部写着“为下雨做好准备”，因为他们会那样做。
And he says, so great weather we're having, huh?
Kind of rainy, you know, but still humid.
But that was it.
That is it.
So I asked Randy about it, and here's what he said.
He said, if I recall correctly, we entered this week expecting rain all across L.A.
In fact, the top of our call sheets for the first two days of shooting say be prepared for rain,
because they would do that.
然后，如果我们是在外面拍摄，他们会为我们准备额外的雨伞和各种各样的东西。兰迪说拍摄的第一天，我们必须拍摄这些和史蒂夫一起的驾驶场景。它们本应该是迈克尔开车往返于他和戴维·华莱士的会议。哦，我有一些。我稍后会播放他离开时的片段。太棒了。因为它们被删了，对吧？没错。好吧，我想当他们在拍摄这个时，雨下得满车都是。雨刷在动，诸如此类。那天下午，他们搬回了我们的停车场，在那里他们必须拍摄安吉拉和凯利试图寻找查尔斯的场景。那是安吉拉你抓住他围巾的那一幕。是的，是的，在雨中。是的。他说整个下午雨一直在下。
And then they would have extra umbrellas and like all kinds of things for us if we were shooting outside.
Randy said the very first day of shooting, we had to shoot these driving scenes with
Steve. They were supposed to be Michael driving to and from his meeting with David Wallace. Oh,
I have some. I'm going to play later for when he leaves. It's amazing. Because they got deleted,
right? That's right. Well, I guess while they were shooting this, it was raining all over the car.
The wipers are going and all that. That afternoon, they moved back to our parking lot where they
had to shoot the scenes of Angela and Kelly trying to find Charles. That's one Angela where you're like
gripping his scarf. Yeah, yeah, in the rain. Yes. He said it was steadily raining the whole afternoon.
太完美了。这变成了一个完整的桥段，我知道我们稍后可以谈到，但这让那个场景变得更有趣了。很有趣，因为当我第一次看到它时，我问兰迪，你们是不是用水管喷洒了停车场？他说，不，那是我们的雨天。是的，实际上是在下雨。这是我在《办公室》拍摄期间，他们不关心我的发型和化妆的唯一几次之一。他们只是说，让她淋湿吧。好吧，我想在我们那天拍摄结束后，有必要让它与这一集的其余部分相匹配。所以迈克尔·加伦伯格和我们的施工协调员蒂姆·詹姆斯，以及由罗恩·纳里领导的特效团队，在所有的办公室窗户上加了有机玻璃板。他们让每一扇窗户在这一集的其余部分都下着雨。
It was perfect. It became a whole bit, which I know we can get to later, but it made the scene that
much more fun. It's funny because when I first saw it, I asked Randy, did you guys spray down the
parking lot with water? And he said, no, that was our rainy day. Yes, it was actually raining.
And it was one of the only times I've filmed on the office where they didn't care about my hair and makeup.
They were just like, let her get wet.
Well, I guess after we finished shooting that one day, it was necessary to match that to the rest of the episode.
So Michael Gallenberg and our construction coordinator, Tim James, and the special effects crew, led by Ron Nary, added plexiglass sheets over all of the office windows.
And they made it rain out every window for the rest of the episode.
好吧，我觉得这太棒了，因为我觉得如果有些场景下雨，有些不下雨会很奇怪。我喜欢这种连贯性。我也很喜欢我们从来没有谈论过它。是的。好吧，还记得你说过你怎么能听到它吗？我想那是个问题，因为我们的混音师本·帕特里克真的能通过麦克风听到它，特别是在采访片段的背景里。所以他们尝试放下这些被称为“马毛”的大毛垫。在金属槽内，水会滴进去，然后它会被吸回去
Well, I think that's so great because I think it would have been weird to have some scenes where it was raining and some not.
I like the consistency.
I also kind of loved it that we never talked about it.
Yeah.
Well, remember what you said about how you could hear it?
I guess that was kind of an issue because our sound mixer, Ben Patrick, could really hear it through the microphones, especially in the back of the talking heads.
So they tried putting down these big fuzzy mats called horse hairs.
inside of the metal troughs that the water would drip into and then it would get sucked back up
那会循环通过窗格，试图让水声安静下来，但它并没有100%起作用。所以你可以在其中一些场景的背景中听到雨声。兰迪还想让我告诉大家，这些毛垫实际上不是用马毛做的。那是我的下一个问题。我说，哦，不。哦，不。为什么它们叫那个名字？
and that would just sort of cycle through the window pane to try to quiet the water,
but it didn't work 100%.
So you can hear the rain in the back of some of these scenes.
Randy also wanted me to tell people that the fuzzy mats are not actually made out of horsehair.
That was my next question.
I said, oh, no.
Oh, no.
Why are they called that?
但是，啊，兰迪说，引用道，“这只是好莱坞早期留下的另一个老式遗留物。”好吧，谢天谢地，因为我刚才担心了一下。它是假毛。假毛。假毛。好吧，这就是我所有的内容了，女士。好吧，我很喜欢所有这些。
But, ah, Brandy said that it's, quote,
just another old-timey holdover from early Hollywood.
Well, thank goodness, because I was worried for a second.
It's faky.
Faky hair.
Well, that's all I got, lady.
Well, I loved all of that.
我们可能应该休息一下，然后进入这一集。我想也是。我今天发明了一个新短语。哦，是吗？嗯哼。你想听听吗？是的。它叫“粉丝邮件狂潮”。
We should probably take a break and then get into this episode.
I think so.
I've invented a new phrase for today.
Oh, yeah?
Uh-huh.
You want to hear it?
Yeah.
It's called the fan mail flurry.
哦。那是我们要用的一个新短语。我们收到大量关于某一集里某个主题的邮件，这周有两个粉丝邮件狂潮。珍娜，创造了一个短语，嗯，我想让你知道，我让我丈夫为这一集做了一个转场音效。我会给你一个惊喜。让我们休息一下，回来继续《新老板》。我们要以会议室里关于迈克尔15周年纪念庆祝活动的小会议开始这一集。谁在派对策划委员会里？现在。吉姆，德怀特和帕姆。哦，我只是在那里做笔记。我觉得我并没有真正参与其中。
Oh.
And that's when we're going to be a new phrase for.
we get tons of mail about a certain one subject in an episode, and this week there were two
fan mail flurries. Jenna, coined a phrase, well, I want you to know, I had my husband make a sting
for this episode. And I will surprise you with it. Let's take a break, and we'll be back with new boss.
We're going to kick off this episode with a little meeting in the conference room about Michael's
15th anniversary celebration. And who is in the party planning committee?
now. Jim, Dwight, and Pam. Oh, I'm just there to take notes. I don't think I'm really in it.
虽然稍后，我想我是在提出想法。你是。嗯。我是怎么回到里面的？我想吉姆把你拉进来了，我要说，叛徒。德怀特要提出一个15分钟掌声，随后是15分钟沉默时刻的想法。那30分钟会是什么样子？如果你是观众。总共30分钟。这对我来说太搞笑了。就像，我知道我们永远不可能做到这一点，但我很想拍摄那个。而且我很想让我们所有人都不得不鼓掌15分钟。
Although later, I guess I am throwing out ideas. You are. Hmm. How'd I make my way back in?
I think Jim wrangled you in and I'm going to say, traitor. Dwight is going to pitch the idea of a 15-minute
round of applause followed by a 15-minute moment of silence. What would that 30 minutes be like?
if you're an audience member.
It's 30 minutes total.
It's so hilarious to me.
Like, I know we could never have done this, but I would have loved to film that.
And I would have loved for all of us to have had to clap for 15 minutes.
那会非常困难。我知道。然后试着看它。好吧，摄像机扫过，吉姆穿着燕尾服。哇，这以后真的会困扰他。他穿着燕尾服。他把头发梳得油光水滑。嗯哼。
That would be so difficult.
I know.
And then try watching it.
Well, the camera pans over, and Jim is wearing a tuxedo.
And, wow, this is really going to haunt him later.
He's wearing a tuxedo.
He's slicked his hair.
Mm-hmm.
他全力以赴，为了在德怀特的着装规范备忘录上让他难堪。德怀特将继续列出吉姆正在否决的活动。吉姆显然在影响迈克尔，对吧？嗯哼。所以德怀特说，一个弦乐四重奏表演优雅的古典音乐。一个被巧克力草莓包围的冰雕。一个迈克尔的冰雕。是的。
He went all out to rub it in Dwight's face about his dress code memo.
Dwight is going to continue to list off activities that Jim is sort of shooting down.
Jim is clearly influencing Michael, right?
Mm-hmm.
So Dwight says a string quartet performing classy Cal music.
An ice sculpture surrounded by chocolate-covered strawberries.
An ice sculpture of Michael.
Yeah.
这个场景本来会继续。其中一部分被剪掉了。在剧本里，吉姆说，你买不到优雅，你教不会优雅，你是天生的。迈克尔有。帕姆有。德怀特说，真的，帕姆有吗？迈克尔说，帕姆的优雅是从她屁股里冒出来的。哇。帕姆说，谢谢你，迈克尔。你这么说真是太优雅了。然后德怀特就像，好吧，我很抱歉我不知道什么是优雅。那太棒了。我喜欢那个。你知道，在这个会议上，他们要决定的事情之一，是优雅的是花生先生。是的。花生先生是Planter's花生公司的标志，听听这个。什么？成立于1906年，在宾夕法尼亚州的威尔克斯-巴里。
This scene would have continued.
Part of it was edited out.
in the script, Jim says, you can't buy Classy, you can't teach Classy, you're born with it. Michael has it. Pam has it. Dwight goes, really, Pam has it? And Michael says, Pam has class coming out of her ass. Wow. Pam says, thank you, Michael. That was very classy of you to say. And then Dwight's like, well, I'm sorry I don't know what classy is. That is amazing. I love that. You know, in this meeting, one of the things they're going to decide,
is classy is Mr. Peanut.
Yes.
Mr. Peanut is the logo for the Planter's Peanut Company, which, listen to this.
What?
Was founded in 1906 in Wilkesbury, Pennsylvania.
哦，那太棒了。那个怎么样？关于花生先生我还有更多要说的。什么？这个花生是广告史上最著名、最具标志性的形象之一。哦，是的。我脑海里立刻就有了。当你提到花生先生时，我脑海里浮现出他戴着帽子，他们有一根手杖和一个小单片眼镜。
Oh, that's awesome.
How about that?
And I have more to say about Mr. Peanut.
What?
This peanut is like one of the best known, most iconic images in advertising history.
Oh, yeah.
I have it in my mind instantly.
When you say Mr. Peanut, I picture him with his hat and they have a cane and a little monocle.
你知道的。你知道花生先生。他站着的时候喜欢把一条腿架在另一条腿上。他确实。是的。所以这就是他的来历。他们举办了一场比赛，让人们为公司设计一个标志，一个名叫安东尼奥·詹蒂莱的年轻小学生提交了一幅拟人化花生的画。他赢得了比赛，得到了5美元。
You know it.
You know Mr. Peanut.
He kind of kicks one leg over the other when he stands.
He does.
Yeah.
So here's where he came from.
They did a contest to have someone design a logo for the company and a young schoolboy by the name of Antonio Gentile submitted a drawing of an anthropomorphic peanut.
and he won the contest and he got $5.
5美元。但我得告诉你，公司的创始人，他的名字叫阿米迪奥·奥比奇，如果我没说错的话，他被这个小男孩深深打动了，以至于他最终支付了他和所有兄弟姐妹的大学学费。哦，我喜欢听这个。所以我想他得到了5美元和一份他自己及他兄弟姐妹的大学教育。有一位名叫安德鲁·沃拉克的商业艺术家添加了钱。单片眼镜，大礼帽和手杖。所以这是一个双人合作。双人合作。然而，
$5.5.
But I'll have you know that the founder of the company, his name was Amidio Obichi, if I'm saying that correctly,
he was so taken with this little boy that he ended up paying his way through college
and all of his siblings way through college.
Oh, I like hearing that.
So I guess he got $5 and a college education for himself and his siblings.
There was a commercial artist named Andrew Wallach who added the money.
Monocle, the Top Hat, and the cane. So it was a bit of a two-hander. A two-hander. However,
情节变得复杂了。什么？有一个有争议的说法，另一位艺术家实际上添加了单片眼镜，大礼帽和手杖。弗兰克·P·克雷西的家人声称是他做的。他是一位威尔克斯-巴里的艺术家，也是萨福克种植园工厂的负责人。他们认为是他做的。所以，妈妈侦探，发生了什么？谢谢你，安吉拉。目前还没有流通的资料能确切地识别出这位艺术家。我们知道那个小男孩开启了一切。但谁添加了单片眼镜、大礼帽和手杖？我们永远不会知道。我们永远不会真正知道。这就是这一集《妈妈侦探》的内容。
the plot thickens. What? There is a disputed claim that a different artist actually added the
monocle, top hat, and cane. The family of Frank P. Creasy claims that he did it. He was a
Wilkesbury artist and also the head of the Suffolk Planter Plant. They think he did it.
So, Mom Detective, what happened?
Thank you, Angela. There are no sources still in circulation that can positively identify the artist.
We know the little boy started at all. But who added the monocle top hat and cane?
We'll never know. We'll never really know.
There you go on this episode of Mom Detective.
如果《妈妈侦探》的每一集都以“我们永远不会知道”结束，那会不会让人不满意？我想很多集都会那样。好吧，我有一件关于剧本的小事要分享。告诉我。因为，你知道，我喜欢这个剧本的拍摄草稿。珍娜和我已经和你们谈过我们是如何有一个场景，然后有时在当下我们会围绕它玩耍，它会在那一刻改变。所以我认为这是一个很好的例子。而且我不认为我们的节目如果没有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔能像这样。
Is that going to be unsatisfying if the episodes of Mom Detective's end with We'll Never Know?
I think many of them will in that way.
Well, I have a little thing to share about the script.
Tell me.
Because, you know, I loved the shooting draft of this script.
And Jenna and I have talked to you guys about how we would have a scene and then sometimes in the moment we'd play around with it and it would change right there in the moment.
So I think this is a great example.
And I don't think our show could have been like this without Steve Carell.
我告诉你为什么。在拍摄草稿中，迈克尔是那个发表关于花生先生完整演讲的人。不是吉姆。迈克尔说，这需要像汽车经销商的盛大开业或花生先生那样优雅。然后德怀特说，花生先生不优雅。他只是一个穿着大礼帽和手杖的普通花生。迈克尔说，这就是让他优雅的原因。但当你观看这一集时，这是一个双人合作。迈克尔说我们需要它像汽车经销商那样优雅。吉姆说，或者花生先生。这是一个双人合作。这让场景好多了，因为那样迈克尔和吉姆就在这件事上串通一气了，对吧？而德怀特是那个局外人。
I'll tell you why.
In the shooting draft, Michael is the one that has the whole speech about Mr. Peanut.
Not Jim. Michael says, this needs to be classy like the grand opening of a car dealership or Mr. Peanut.
And then Dwight says Mr. Peanut's not classy. He's just a regular peanut dressed in a top hat and cane.
And Michael says, that's what makes him classy. But when you watch the episode, it's a two-hander.
Michael says we need it to be classy like a car dealership. Jim says are Mr. Peanut. And it's a two-hander.
And it makes the scene so much better because then Michael and Jim are kind of in cahoots about this, right?
And Dwight's the odd man out.
我敢打赌那是当天发生的。是的。太棒了。那不是很酷吗？我知道这些都是微小的时刻，但我认为这说明了我们在节目中的创造性合作。绝对。安吉拉，这个开场白也创造了粉丝邮件狂潮第一条。好的。
I bet that happened on the day.
Yeah.
That's so great.
Isn't that cool?
I know these are sort of tiny moments, but I just think it speaks to our creative collaboration on the show.
Absolutely.
Angela, this cold open also created fan mail flurry number one.
Okay.
我觉得我需要一个转场音效。你提到了转场音效，现在我想要一个粉丝邮件狂潮，就像东西进入收件箱一样。人们有很多话要说，关于这是否是迈克尔在邓德·米夫林的第15年？哦。让我从麦迪·L开始。粉丝邮件，粉丝邮件，粉丝邮件，狂潮！嘿！
I feel like I need a sting.
You mentioned sting and now I want a fan mail flurry, like stuff going into an inbox.
People have a lot to say about whether.
or not, this is Michael's 15th year at Dunder Mifflin or not?
Ooh.
Let me get you started with Maddie L.
Fanmail, fan mail, fan mail, flurry!
Hey!
我喜欢！麦迪说，根据这一集的播出日期，迈克尔应该是在1994年3月19日开始在邓德·米夫林工作的。但在迈克尔最后一次邓迪奖期间，演员们演唱了歌曲《9,986,000分钟》，以纪念他在公司工作了多久。如果你从那个播出日期算起，那意味着迈克尔实际上在邓德·米夫林工作了19年。太多数学了。
I love it!
Maddie says,
per this episode's air date,
Michael would have started work at Dunder Mifflin on March 19, 1994.
But during Michael's last Dundies,
The cast sings the song, 9,986,000 minutes in tribute to how long he's worked at the company.
And if you do the math from that air date, that would mean that Michael actually worked at Dunder Mifflin for 19 years.
So much math.
如果你把它倒推到这一集，那此时就是17年。嗯。凯利·S参与了进来，并说，在第三季的谈判中，达里尔说迈克尔已经在邓德·米夫林工作了14年。这是两年后，所以那将是他的第16年。嗯哼。嗯哼。迈克尔在邓德·米夫林工作了多久？
If you back it up to this episode, that would be 17 years at this point.
Huh.
Kelly S got in on this.
and said, in the negotiation from season three, Daryl says that Michael has been working at Dunder Mifflin for 14 years.
This is two years later, so that would make this his 16th year.
Mm-hmm.
How long has Michael been working at Dunder Mifflin?
它在变动。15，16，17年？这感觉就像考试里的那些数学应用题，关于那列去宾夕法尼亚州的火车，但随后在纽约停下来，等等，等等，伙计们。我见过老师这样做，他们会用《办公室》的角色来做数学应用题。我觉得那真的很有趣。我也是。不过我还是不擅长。
It's shifting.
15, 16, 17 years?
This feels like one of those math word problems on a test, like about the train that goes to Pennsylvania.
but then stops off in New York and blah, blah, blah, guys.
I've seen teachers do that where they'll do a math word problem using office characters and stuff.
I think that's really fun.
I do too.
I still wouldn't be good at it, though.
不，因为那还是数学。宾果。你在学校数学好吗？因为我在学校数学非常好。现在，我的意思是，每个人都知道我的计算器故事，我尝试一年不使用计算器进行加法，它离我而去了。就像，我现在几乎不能帮我10岁的孩子做数学作业了。好吧，我怎么了？
No, because it's still math.
Bingo.
Were you good in math in school?
Because I was very good at math in school.
And now, I mean, everyone knows my calculator story where I tried to add without a calculator for a year.
and I don't know, it's left me.
Like, I can barely help my 10-year-old with his math homework now.
Well, what happened to me?
我的意思是，我真的很好。我就像，你知道，数学测试的第98百分位之类的。我在数学上是一个稳固的B等生。完全没问题，一直到代数2。然后我有选择语言而不是三角学的选项。我喜欢语言。我喜欢说其他语言。所以我实际上一直学到了西班牙语4。
I mean, I was really good.
I was like, you know, 98th percentile in the math tests and stuff.
I was a solid, like, B student in math.
Totally fine, all the way up to algebra two.
And then I had the option to take language over trig.
And I love language.
I love speaking other languages.
And so I actually went all the way up to Spanish 4.
但我能够选择放弃三角学去学语言。我喜欢三角学。我不喜欢几何，但我喜欢三角学，代数，所有这些。是的。但它离我而去了。让我们回到这一集，因为一位名叫查尔斯的绅士已经到达，他想和迈克尔谈谈。等等，但首先，我有一个非常高的植物警报。
But I was able to opt out of trig to do language.
I loved trigonometry.
I didn't take it.
I didn't care for geometry, but I loved trigonometry, algebra, all of that.
Yeah.
But it has left me.
Let's get back to the episode because a gentleman named Charles has arrived and he would like to speak with Michael.
Hold up, but first, I have a very tall plant alert.
发生了什么？我们已经很久没有接待处植物警报了，2分23秒。这可能是帕姆最高的盆栽植物。我只是想记录在案。你知道，很有趣。我刚才在看摩根画的帕姆植物的水彩画。是的。
What's happening?
We haven't had a plant at reception alert.
in a long time, two minutes, 23 seconds.
This might be Pam's tallest potted plant.
I just want to go on record.
You know, it's interesting.
I was just looking at the watercolor that Morgan did of Pam's plants.
Yes.
上面有一株植物非常，非常高。它在角落里。它太高了，实际上侵占了其他植物之一。这会是那株植物吗？也许是。我们谈论的帕姆植物的水彩画是由这位出色的艺术家完成的。她的名字叫摩根。
There is a plant on there that's very, very tall.
It's down in the corner.
It's so tall it actually encroaches on one of the other plants.
Could this be that plant?
Maybe it is.
The watercolor painting of Pam's plants that we're talking about is done by this fantastic
artist.
Her name is Morgan.
你可以在Instagram上找到她。Morgan G-E-E-S-E-L-A-R-T。伙计们，她画了帕姆所有的植物。她称之为“比斯利的植物学”。你可以把它作为马克杯，她好心地送了我原版水彩画，我视若珍宝。我知道。你知道她做了什么吗？她把安吉拉·马丁所有的服装都画成了水彩画。
You can find her on Instagram.
Morgan G-E-E-S-E-L-A-R-T.
You guys, she's painted all of Pam's plants.
She calls it Beasley's Botanicals.
You can get it as a mug, and she was kind enough to gift me with the original watercolor, which I treasure.
I know.
And you know what she did?
She did all of Angela Martin's outfits in a watercolor painting.
我把它挂在我的卧室里。所以，是的，接待处有一株非常高的植物。我没注意到那株植物，安吉拉，因为我的眼睛在伊德里斯·艾尔巴进入房间时。是的，查尔斯·迈纳先生已经到达。在2分50秒，安吉拉·马丁上下打量了他。迈克尔欢迎他进来，并说每个人都需要去休息室，因为他有一个他正在准备的惊喜。是的，他向德怀特耳语，我得准备好鱼。是的。恶心。什么是什么？现在是我想称之为“休息室里的历史”的环节。
I have it hanging in my bedroom.
So, yes, there is a very tall plant at reception.
I didn't notice the plant, Angela, because my eyes.
were on Idraselba entering the room. Yes, Sir Charles Minor has arrived. At two minutes, 50 seconds,
Angela Martin looks him up and down. Michael welcomes him in and says that everybody needs to go
into the break room because he has a surprise that he is setting up. Yeah, he whispers to Dwight,
I have to get the fish ready. Yep. Gross. What's a what? And now for a segment I'd like to call
History in the break room.
在休息室里。我昨晚让我丈夫在车里做了那个。你可以看出来。我说，在车里做，在小型货车里。听起来会更好。休息室里的历史。所以迈克尔需要德怀特去分散查尔斯和团队的注意力。他们去了休息室。
In the break room.
I made my husband do that like last night in his car.
You can tell.
I'm like, do it in the car, in the minivan.
It'll sound better.
History in the break room.
So Michael needs Dwight to distract Charles and the group.
They go in the break room.
他用斯克兰顿的历史让他们感到厌烦。我们只听到了这一句。而且我也记得雷恩很难不笑，你可以看到他开始破功时那种闪烁的眼神。你知道剧本里有一整段演讲吗？我知道，因为我记得雷恩必须背诵一大段关于斯克兰顿历史的独白。特别是无烟煤煤矿社区。伙计们，当我们看到这一集只有一行台词保留下来时，我只是知道雷恩当时是，
He bores them with the history of Scranton.
We only hear one sentence of this.
And I also remember Rain had a hard time not laughing.
and you can kind of see him starting that twinkle when he starts to break.
Do you know there was a whole entire speech in the script?
I do because I remember that Rain had to memorize a huge monologue about the history of Scranton.
In particular, the anthracite coal mining communities.
You guys, when we saw the episode in only one line made it, I just know Rain was like,
该死的，这就是他必须学习的内容。最初成立于1866年，斯克兰顿迅速成为宾夕法尼亚州最大的无烟煤煤矿社区之一。二战期间国家对能源的渴望被该地区广泛的露天采矿作业所满足。但在1959年，诺克斯矿难几乎抹去了当地的采矿业。该地区随后被废弃的煤矿结构、露天矿和矿渣堆所破坏，这些都为这座城市的工业过去提供了无声的证明。所以无论如何，你最近怎么样？你能相信他学了整件事，只有一行保留下来吗？第一行和最后一行保留了下来。
Son of a, this is what he had to learn.
Originally founded in 1866, Scranton quickly became one of Pennsylvania's largest anthracite coal mining communities.
The nation's thirst for energy during World War II was slacked by the extensive strip mining operations in the area.
But in 1959, the Knox mine disaster all but erased the local mining industry.
The area was then scarred by abandoned coal mining structures, strip mines, and slag heaps, which give mute testimony to the city's industrial past.
So anyway, what's up with you?
Can you believe he learned that whole thing and one line made it?
The first line and the ending line made it.
该死，这就是他必须学习的内容。斯克兰顿始建于1866年，很快就成为了宾夕法尼亚州最大的无烟煤矿社区之一。二战期间，该地区大规模的露天开采作业满足了全国对能源的渴求。但在1959年，诺克斯矿难几乎摧毁了当地的采矿业。此后，该地区留下了废弃的煤矿设施、露天矿坑和矿渣堆，这些都成为了该市工业历史的无声见证。总之，你最近怎么样？你能相信他学了那么多，最后只有一行被用上了吗？只有第一行和最后一行被用上了。
Oh, my gosh.
Well, then Michael is going to come in and he says, all right, everybody, come to the conference room.
And you know, he does that big gesture where his hand hits the door frame.
Yeah, he does this windmill motion.
And then he does the thing that Steve does so well where he's like, oh, yeah, right?
where he like grunts. It was the same thing that cracked me up when he would get out of Pam's chair
after it had sunk down. Or when Kevin sat on him as Santa. It's the same noise. It's like,
oh. Yeah, he does. These suppressed groans so well. Well, that whole thing was scripted.
天哪。然后迈克尔走进来，他说，好了，大家，到会议室来。你知道，他做了那个标志性的动作，手撞到了门框上。是的，他做了那个风车般的动作。然后他做了史蒂夫非常擅长的那个动作，就是那种，哦，是吗？那种咕哝声。这和我当初看他从帕姆那把下沉的椅子上站起来时被逗乐的是同一个动作。或者当凯文扮成圣诞老人坐在他身上时。是同样的噪音。就像，哦。是的，他确实是这样。他非常擅长这种压抑的呻吟。好吧，整件事都是写好的剧本。
I looked it up and this is what the script said about that. It says,
Michael Windmill motions for people to follow, but nails his hand on top of the entrance,
he winces. So that little moment was scripted for Steve.
And he was amazing.
He was amazing because you're not sure.
You're not sure if that was just him mucking around or if it really happened.
Well, once in the conference room, Michael is going to present an array of bagels that have been cut into the shape of a C for Charles.
Took them all night.
我查了一下，剧本里是这样写的。它说，迈克尔做了一个风车动作示意大家跟上，但他的手撞到了入口上方，他疼得龇牙咧嘴。所以那个小瞬间是为史蒂夫设计的。他演得太棒了。他之所以棒，是因为你无法确定。你无法确定那是他即兴发挥的，还是真的发生了。好吧，到了会议室，迈克尔要展示一系列切成C形的百吉饼，代表查尔斯。他花了一整晚时间。
Yeah.
I have to say when I saw this, I thought this was a very Ted Lassow move.
Could you see Ted Lassow and beard doing something like this?
Like making all the bagels.
into like a certain letter.
Am I crazy?
No, it's a Ted Lassau.
I can see it.
是的。我不得不说，当我看到这一幕时，我觉得这非常有泰德·拉索的风格。你能想象泰德·拉索和比尔德做这样的事吗？比如把所有的百吉饼做成某个字母。是我疯了吗？不，这就是泰德·拉索。我能想象出来。
And this just got my brain
sort of thinking about how
there are actually a lot of things
that Michael does,
that Ted Lassow also kind of does.
But he does it better
and more appropriate.
You guys were talking about the show
这让我开始思考，迈克尔做的很多事情，泰德·拉索其实也做过。但他做得更好，也更得体。你们当时在谈论这部剧
Ted Lassow with Jason Sadecas,
Bill Lawrence,
executive produced the show.
He's amazing.
It just won a gazillion Emmys.
The cast is phenomenal.
But I was just watching an episode
the other day where Ted Lassow is like
泰德·拉索由杰森·苏戴奇斯、比尔·劳伦斯担任执行制片人。他太棒了。它刚刚赢得了无数艾美奖。演员阵容非常出色。但我前几天刚看了一集，泰德·拉索正在
riding,
lawnmower with the guy.
Uh-huh.
Couldn't you see Michael Scott doing that?
Michael and Dwight?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I was seeing some parallels, and it was kind of charming me.
和那个人一起骑割草机。嗯哼。你难道看不出迈克尔·斯科特会那样做吗？迈克尔和德怀特？是的。我不知道。我看到了一些相似之处，这让我觉得很有魅力。
And I think also because I thought it was kind of cute that he made the bagels into a sea.
I did too.
It's just that his presentation of it was so sad.
It was just on a bunch of paper towels.
Well, and also, like, just his buildup.
His buildup was so huge.
Yeah.
Oh.
而且我觉得他把百吉饼做成C形挺可爱的。我也这么觉得。只是他的展示方式太悲惨了。就放在一堆纸巾上。嗯，还有，他的铺垫。他的铺垫太隆重了。是的。哦。
Ted would have had them on a tray.
And that would have made the difference.
Yeah.
And he's also Ted and not Michael.
Anyway, we both love Ted Lassow, if you can't tell.
Clearly, we just like it.
Michael has a talking hit.
He's super excited about what his relationship's going to be like with Charles.
泰德会把它们放在托盘上。那就会大不相同了。是的。而且他是泰德，不是迈克尔。总之，如果我们没说出来的话，我们俩都爱泰德·拉索。很明显，我们就是喜欢它。迈克尔有一个采访镜头。他对他和查尔斯的关系会是什么样感到超级兴奋。
They hung out at corporate.
They got along.
He said, it's going to be mental.
He's so excited.
You guys, did you notice that this scene starts off with Creed walking out of the conference room,
just eating salmon out of his hand?
No.
He's just thrown.
他们在总公司待过。他们相处得很好。他说，这会很棒。他太兴奋了。你们注意到这一幕开始时，克里德正走出会议室，直接用手抓着吃三文鱼吗？没有。他只是把
salmon in his mouth. You can only see him from the back. It's such a small detail. I was cracking up.
You know, for a technical reason, they needed Creed or someone to leave the conference room because then the
camera follows that person to Angela and Kelly. And Creed, I know, I know he just was eating that
fish. That was not in the script. This is when Charles is going to notice Jim's tucks.
Oh, they get off to a bumpy start. They really, really do. Pam has to like gentlemen.
pulled Jim away. That was really hard for me. I would laugh every time I had to do that because it was
funny to me. It was so funny. And you guys, right after this awkward meeting between Jim and Charles
and Pam pulling him away, there was a Charles Minor talking head. What was it? Okay. Oh, I wish it
三文鱼扔进嘴里。你只能从背后看到他。这是一个非常小的细节。我当时笑疯了。你知道，出于技术原因，他们需要克里德或某人离开会议室，因为摄像机随后要跟随那个人去安吉拉和凯莉那里。而克里德，我知道，我知道他只是在吃那条鱼。那不在剧本里。这是查尔斯注意到吉姆穿燕尾服的时候。哦，他们开局很糟糕。真的，非常糟糕。帕姆不得不像绅士一样把吉姆拉开。那对我来说真的很难。我每次不得不这样做时都会笑，因为我觉得这很有趣。太搞笑了。而且你们，就在吉姆和查尔斯之间这次尴尬的会面之后，帕姆把他拉开，有一个查尔斯·迈纳的采访镜头。是什么？好吧。哦，我真希望
would have made it. This is what they would have cut to. In business school, they taught us how to assess
operations and identify waste. It's rare the waist so readily identifies itself. So it's very clear
if that had stayed in how Charles sees Jim. Well, Pam and Jim have a talking head together.
And in this talking head, Pam says he just had to wear his tucks today. Took him 40 minutes to get
ready. She's so amused. We got a fan question from Lola C. and A.K. Sangra. Why didn't Jim just take off
his blazer and tie?
because then it would have just been like kind of a white button down shirt and pants.
I don't think it would have mattered.
它能保留下来。这是他们原本要剪辑进去的内容。在商学院，他们教我们如何评估运营和识别浪费。很少有浪费能如此轻易地自我识别。所以如果这段保留下来，很清楚查尔斯是怎么看吉姆的。好吧，帕姆和吉姆一起接受了采访。在这个采访中，帕姆说他今天非得穿他的燕尾服。他花了40分钟准备。她觉得很好笑。我们收到了来自Lola C.和A.K. Sangra的粉丝提问。为什么吉姆不直接脱掉西装外套和领带？因为那样的话，看起来就像是一件普通的白色衬衫和裤子。我觉得那没什么区别。
It's a weird white shirt, right?
It does have the tuxedo collar.
Yeah.
But it would have helped.
It would have maybe helped a little.
I'm going to say good point, guys.
This whole dynamic of Jim and Charles getting off on the wrong foot, this is going to extend, you know, because Idris is going to be on for five more episodes.
And this is going to extend through this whole story.
那是一件奇怪的白衬衫，对吧？它确实有燕尾服的领子。是的。但那会有所帮助。也许会有一点帮助。我要说，你们说得有道理。吉姆和查尔斯关系不和的这种动态，会持续下去，你知道，因为伊德里斯还要再演五集。这将贯穿整个故事
line with him. And this was a dynamic. Gene and Lee told me that the writers really wanted to examine.
They loved this idea that someone was going to put Jim back on his heels, that there was a character
that was immune to Jim's charm and wit. And they thought it would be very, very funny to see
Jim be so disarmed. It was. I couldn't get enough of it. I loved it. I loved John,
everything about John having to play this piece of his character.
And you know John had so much fun. That was just always really cool when you got to examine another side of your character.
I loved that too. I always loved when there would be little shifts like when Pam and Dwight were friends.
Yeah. You know? I love suspicious bitch, you know. So.
线。这是一种编剧们真的很想探讨的动态。他们喜欢这种想法，即有人会把吉姆逼到墙角，有一个角色对吉姆的魅力和机智免疫。他们认为看到吉姆如此被解除武装会非常非常有趣。确实如此。我怎么看都不够。我喜欢约翰，喜欢约翰扮演这个角色侧面的所有一切。而且你知道约翰玩得很开心。当你能探索角色的另一面时，总是非常酷。我也喜欢那样。我总是喜欢那些小小的转变，比如当帕姆和德怀特成为朋友的时候。是的。你知道吗？我喜欢那个多疑的婊子，你知道。所以。
But now, one of my favorite elements of our show is when Michael has to introduce a new person to anyone in the office.
He gets so personal. He has done.
done this time and time again. He brings over the accounting department and then tells all of our
dating history. He tells about Oscars breakup with Gill and how Angela has had sexual relations with
Andy. And then Idris just interrupts him and is like, you know, Michael, I don't need to know
everyone's sexual history. And he's like, good, because we're getting to Kevin and he's got nada.
I just love it every time. Every time I look forward to it. Like the writers must have loved having to come up
with new ways for Michael to introduce the same people.
但现在，我们剧中最喜欢的元素之一是迈克尔必须向办公室里的任何人介绍新人的时候。他变得非常私人。他一次又一次地这样做。他把会计部门叫过来，然后讲述我们所有的约会历史。他讲述了奥斯卡和吉尔的分手，以及安吉拉如何与安迪发生过性关系。然后伊德里斯打断了他，说，你知道，迈克尔，我不需要知道每个人的性史。然后他说，太好了，因为我们要讲到凯文了，他什么都没有。我每次都喜欢这个。每次我都期待着它。就像编剧们一定很喜欢想出新的方式让迈克尔介绍同样的人。
It really reminds me of how children, like, sometimes introduce people.
Yes.
Like, my mom has the story of me.
I was probably, like, eight years old, and we were at the grocery store checkout.
And it was me and my mom and my friend.
And the woman thought my friend was my mom's daughter.
And she was like, oh, she looks just like you.
And I said, that's not her daughter.
这真的让我想起孩子们有时是如何介绍人的。是的。比如，我妈妈有关于我的故事。我当时大概八岁，我们在杂货店结账。当时是我、我妈妈和我朋友。那个女人以为我朋友是我妈妈的女儿。她说，哦，她长得真像你。我说，那不是她的女儿。
I'm her daughter.
My mom dies her hair.
And my mom was like, thank you.
But that's how Michael introduces people.
No, it's true.
He's like, hmm, how can I introduce this person?
You know what?
They only have eight toes.
我是她的女儿。我妈妈染了头发。我妈妈说，谢谢。但迈克尔就是这样介绍人的。不，这是真的。他会说，嗯，我该怎么介绍这个人呢？你知道吗？他们只有八个脚趾。
What?
Here's something interesting.
Charles clearly realizes he needs to take over here for a second.
He's all business.
He is.
And he wants everybody to know that Dunder Mifflin is cutting 3% across the board.
They will no longer be matching 401K contributions.
All over time has to go through corporate.
什么？这里有一件有趣的事。查尔斯显然意识到他需要在这里接管一下。他全是公事公办。他是。他想让每个人都知道邓德·米夫林正在全面削减3%的开支。他们将不再匹配401K缴款。所有加班费都必须经过总公司审批。
And here's the big one.
They're putting a freeze on discretionary spending, including parties.
Petty cash supplies and parties.
Oh boy.
Oh, boy.
And immediately Michael starts to spiral.
He's like, okay, Charles, thanks for coming in.
Thank you.
还有最重要的一点。他们冻结了可自由支配的支出，包括派对。零用金、办公用品和派对。天哪。天哪。迈克尔立刻开始失控。他说，好吧，查尔斯，谢谢你过来。谢谢。
Thank you so much.
And Charles is like, no, I'm actually going to stay today.
And we got some mail about that.
people were like, why is David Wallace having Charles Minor babysit Michael all day when just a couple
episodes ago he was so impressed with Michael that he was sending him out to speak to other branches?
I never saw this as Charles babysitting Michael in particular. I just saw this as this guy who's new to
the company, he's an executive, he's just going to go around to every branch and spend a day at the
branch. He's going to get to know the people. He's clearly going to bring them lunch. You know, this wasn't a
非常感谢。查尔斯说，不，我今天实际上要留下来。我们收到了一些关于此的邮件。人们问，为什么大卫·华莱士让查尔斯·迈纳整天盯着迈克尔，而就在几集前，他对迈克尔印象深刻，还派他去和其他分部讲话？我从来没觉得这是查尔斯在盯着迈克尔。我只是觉得这是一个刚加入公司的人，他是一位高管，他只是要走访每个分部，在分部待上一天。他要了解这些人。他显然会给他们带午餐。你知道，这并不是一个
babysitting thing where Michael was singled out, this is just what he's doing to kind of get to know people.
Exactly. This is standard practice. He's the VP of the Northeast region. He's got to get to know his region.
Well, while Charles is setting up in the conference room, Michael's going to get David Wallace on the phone because it was his understanding that he would not be managed.
This is one of my favorite lines that Michael says in the whole episode. Yeah. He's telling David, he says to David, he doesn't understand why they
can't just leave the position vacant. And then here's my favorite line. Truth be told, I think I thrive
under a lack of accountability. Michael asked David if he will be attending his anniversary party,
and if hiring Cirque de Soleil performers as salaried employees would help with the year-end tax stuff.
No response. I counted. It's a seven-second silence. It's so perfect. And then Dwight,
盯着人的事情，迈克尔只是被单独挑出来，这只是他为了了解人们而做的事情。完全正确。这是标准做法。他是东北地区副总裁。他必须了解他的区域。好吧，当查尔斯在会议室布置时，迈克尔要给大卫·华莱士打电话，因为他的理解是他不会被管理。这是迈克尔在整集中我最喜欢的台词之一。是的。他告诉大卫，他告诉大卫，他不明白为什么他们不能让这个职位空缺。然后是我最喜欢的台词。说实话，我觉得我在缺乏问责的情况下反而能茁壮成长。迈克尔问大卫是否会参加他的周年纪念派对，以及雇佣太阳马戏团的表演者作为受薪员工是否有助于年终税务问题。没有回应。我数了数。有七秒钟的沉默。太完美了。然后德怀特，
who, by the way, they revealed was there the whole time. It's classic Michael
Dwight's like, maybe, maybe he hung up. And then he's like, no. Michael comes out of this phone call.
He's decided, all right, he's going to try to get to know Charles. He's going to make an effort.
He's going to ask him some personal questions right away. He's like, tell me something you've
never told anyone before. Charles is like, no. And before we get any further into this crazy meeting,
because there is a scene that was deleted that I want to read to you. Let's take a break.
Yes, let's take a break and we'll be right back.
All right, so we're back.
顺便说一下，他们揭示了德怀特一直都在那里。这是典型的迈克尔，德怀特说，也许，也许他挂了。然后他说，不。迈克尔打完这个电话出来。他决定，好吧，他要试着去了解查尔斯。他要做出努力。他要立刻问他一些私人问题。他说，告诉我一些你从未告诉过任何人的事情。查尔斯说，不。在我们继续深入这个疯狂的会议之前，因为有一个被删减的场景我想读给你们听。我们休息一下吧。是的，我们休息一下，马上回来。好了，我们回来了。
We're in the conference room.
Michael is desperately trying to get to know Charles Minor.
Charles Minor is having none of it.
I know somewhere in an NBC vault, there's got to be tons of extra footage because
in the script there were all these bits and you know Steve went off script.
So the scene would have started like this.
Hi Charles.
Hi, Michael.
我们在会议室。迈克尔拼命想了解查尔斯·迈纳。查尔斯·迈纳根本不吃这一套。我知道在NBC的某个金库里，一定有大量的额外镜头，因为剧本里有所有这些片段，而且你知道史蒂夫脱离了剧本。所以场景原本是这样开始的。嗨，查尔斯。嗨，迈克尔。
And then Michael would go, Charles, Charles, Charles, Burrall's, Banana, Fana, Fana.
And then he stops and the script says,
Long beat.
And then he goes,
Mimo, Mo Marles,
very long beat.
And then at the same time,
Charles goes Michael,
然后迈克尔会说，查尔斯，查尔斯，查尔斯，伯拉尔斯，香蕉，法纳，法纳。然后他停下来，剧本写着，长停顿。然后他说，米莫，莫，马尔斯，非常长的停顿。然后同时，查尔斯说，迈克尔，
and Michael goes Charles.
That's how it would have started.
Wow.
I'm sad that's not there.
Well, instead, Michael asks Charles
two questions in a row.
What is your wife's name?
And where did you work before this?
迈克尔说，查尔斯。这就是开始的方式。哇。我很遗憾那段不在。好吧，相反，迈克尔连续问了查尔斯两个问题。你妻子的名字是什么？你在这之前在哪里工作？
And Charles says,
Saddakoi Steel.
And Michael says,
Oh, what a cool name for your wife.
And he's like, no, I worked at Sattacoys Steel.
And the performance by Steve as Michael, when he realizes that Charles isn't even a paper man.
Yeah.
He's like, does David Wallace know this?
查尔斯说，萨塔科伊钢铁公司。迈克尔说，哦，你妻子的名字真酷。他说，不，我在萨塔科伊钢铁公司工作。史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔，当他意识到查尔斯甚至不是造纸行业的人时，那段表演。是的。他说，大卫·华莱士知道这件事吗？
You don't even come from paper.
Yeah.
We got a lot of fan mail about the Sattacoys Steel.
People noticed that we film on Satticois Street.
Yeah.
And they wanted to know, was this a real?
company or just a nod to where we filmed. It is not a real company. It was just named after our street.
And I love it. I did too. However, I did find this when I was looking up Satakoi Steel.
你甚至不是做纸张的。是的。我们收到了很多关于萨塔科伊钢铁公司的粉丝邮件。人们注意到我们在萨塔科伊街拍摄。是的。他们想知道，这是一个真实的公司，还是仅仅是对我们拍摄地点的致敬。这不是一家真实的公司。它只是以我们的街道命名的。我喜欢它。我也喜欢。然而，我在查找萨塔科伊钢铁公司时发现了这个。
Would you find Mom Detective? I found out that there is a profile for Charles Minor,
regional manager of Sattacoys Steel on LinkedIn. Oh, great. As well as profiles for all the office
characters. There's like a ton of Dwight K. Shrewt profiles, but you can find all of us on LinkedIn.
I love that. You are very right, Angela, when you say that Michael is very furious to find out
that Charles has not worked in paper, and he calls David Wallace immediately. He does this thing,
as my dad would say, he went in there wide open. Oh. That was an expression my dad would say,
which meant here comes hell, right? So Michael is in a frenzy.
now. There was a scene that led up to his phone call to David between him and Dwight, and they are
你发现了什么，妈妈侦探？我发现LinkedIn上有一个萨塔科伊钢铁公司区域经理查尔斯·迈纳的个人资料。哦，太棒了。还有所有办公室角色的个人资料。有成吨的德怀特·K·舒鲁特的个人资料，但你们可以在LinkedIn上找到我们所有人。我喜欢这个。安吉拉，你说得非常对，迈克尔发现查尔斯没有从事过纸张行业时非常愤怒，他立刻给大卫·华莱士打了电话。他做了这件事，正如我爸爸会说的，他毫无防备地冲了进去。哦。那是我爸爸会说的一句表达，意思是地狱要来了，对吧？所以迈克尔现在处于疯狂状态。在他给大卫打电话之前，他和德怀特之间有一个场景，他们正在
pacing, and they're speaking in hush tones. While Michael's dialing, Dwight's saying nothing, not even
paper plates. Michael's like, nothing. The man is a still worker. He probably has no idea how paper's made.
Hello? And then the phone picks up. That's the energy that would have started the scene that was in the script.
And Michael cannot get David Wallace on the phone. Dwight says you cannot give up so easily.
All right, you've got to charm them.
Rain could not get through this scene.
It's in the bloopers.
We have to hear it.
踱步，压低声音说话。当迈克尔拨号时，德怀特说，什么都没有，连纸盘都没有。迈克尔说，什么都没有。这个人是个钢铁工人。他可能根本不知道纸是怎么造出来的。喂？然后电话接通了。这就是剧本中那个场景开始时的能量。迈克尔无法接通大卫·华莱士的电话。德怀特说你不能这么轻易放弃。好吧，你得去讨好他们。雷恩无法完成这个场景。它在花絮里。我们必须听听。
David Wallace's office.
Hey, they're gorgeous.
How you doing today?
I'm good, thank you.
How's it hanging?
All right.
Listen, my name.
He doesn't even sound like Dwight.
大卫·华莱士的办公室。嘿，他们很漂亮。你今天怎么样？我很好，谢谢。最近怎么样？好吧。听着，我的名字。他听起来甚至不像德怀特。
That's the other thing that I think.
He sounds like rain.
He does sound like rain.
I think that kind of cracked Rain up.
David Wallace's assistant,
was played by Suzanne Watson.
I'm not exactly sure how she got the role in the show.
She mostly works as a producer,
这是我认为的另一件事。他听起来像雷恩。他确实听起来像雷恩。我想这让雷恩笑场了。大卫·华莱士的助理，由苏珊·沃森饰演。我不确定她是怎么得到这个角色的。她主要担任制片人，
but she is going to appear in three more episodes of the office in season six,
and she would have had a scene in this episode as well
when Michael eventually goes to corporate.
So she wasn't just cast for her voice.
She actually, you know, was going to have this recurring role
as David Wallace's assistant.
And she will.
Stephanie.
但她将在第六季的《办公室》中再出现三集，而且如果迈克尔最终去总公司，她在这个场景中也会有一个镜头。所以她不仅仅是因为声音被选中的。她实际上，你知道，要扮演大卫·华莱士助理这个常驻角色。她会的。斯蒂芬妮。
Oh, to be Stephanie, taking Michael's calls.
Oh, man.
So meanwhile, Jim is working at his desk and his tucks, and he keeps looking over his shoulder, and Charles is there.
Yes.
Looking at him through the blinds of the conference room.
And then it pans to Jim, and Jim, like, shakes off the camera like, mm-mm, mm-mm.
And then it whips over to Dwight, and Dwight is so smug and happy.
斯蒂芬妮。哦，成为斯蒂芬妮，接听迈克尔的电话。哦，天哪。与此同时，吉姆穿着燕尾服在办公桌前工作，他不停地回头看，查尔斯就在那里。是的。透过会议室的百叶窗看着他。然后镜头转向吉姆，吉姆像是在甩掉摄像机，不，不。然后镜头迅速转向德怀特，德怀特非常自鸣得意，很高兴。
Well, in the script, Dwight had a talking head here.
It got deleted, but you got to hear it.
Oh, look at me in my pretty tuxedo.
I'm so pretty and carefree and I don't need glasses.
And, oh, what's that?
An objective outside observer doesn't find me amusing.
Hysterical.
That's pretty great.
好吧，在剧本里，德怀特在这里有一个采访镜头。它被删减了，但你必须听听。哦，看看我穿着漂亮的燕尾服。我真漂亮，无忧无虑，而且我不需要眼镜。哦，那是什么？一个客观的外部观察者觉得我不有趣。歇斯底里。那太棒了。
This is making Dwight's year.
Hey, guess what?
What?
Lunch is here.
And it's on me.
Charles got lunch for everybody.
People are thrilled.
Michael's like, I wish you would have told us sooner.
这让德怀特这一年都过得很开心。嘿，猜猜怎么着？什么？午餐到了。我请客。查尔斯给每个人买了午餐。大家都很激动。迈克尔说，我希望你能早点告诉我们。
I was going to go to the vending machine and get an egg salad.
I'm sorry, is there egg salad?
in our vending machines?
Gross.
What? Vending machine is this?
We did not have a refrigerated vending machine.
No.
Charles, though, is like you still have that option.
我本来打算去自动售货机买个鸡蛋沙拉。抱歉，我们的自动售货机里有鸡蛋沙拉吗？恶心。什么？这是什么自动售货机？我们没有冷藏自动售货机。没有。不过查尔斯说，你仍然有那个选择。
There's some serious Charles sass in this scene.
And my favorite is this one.
I do this for every branch I go to.
If you do not like it, then I think there are some bagels left over from this morning.
Sass.
That's major sass.
Well, you know, in the conference room, Kelly's going to say to Angela, should I seduce Charles?
And Angela goes, no, no one wants to see that.
这一幕里有很严重的查尔斯式的傲慢。我最喜欢的是这一句。我去的每个分部都这样做。如果你不喜欢，那么我想今天早上剩下的百吉饼还有一些。傲慢。那是严重的傲慢。好吧，你知道，在会议室里，凯莉要对安吉拉说，我应该诱惑查尔斯吗？安吉拉说，不，没人想看那个。
But then she sneaks a smile at Charles.
I like this rivalry.
Mindy and I had so much fun doing this.
We had such a blast.
Michael is trying to call David Wallace again.
And then we're going to have the scene that is the tipping point for Michael.
It's so cringy.
Kevin approaches Michael and says he used the wrong calendar for his spreadsheet.
但随后她偷偷对查尔斯笑了笑。我喜欢这种竞争。明迪和我做这个非常开心。我们玩得很尽兴。迈克尔正试图再次给大卫·华莱士打电话。然后我们将看到迈克尔的转折点场景。太尴尬了。凯文走近迈克尔，说他用了错误的日历来做电子表格。
The wrong calendar.
From 2008.
And he has to redo his spreadsheet.
Can he come in over the weekend?
That would mean overtime.
Michael says yes.
Charles says no.
No, we talked about this.
错误的日历。2008年的。他必须重做电子表格。他周末能来吗？那意味着加班。迈克尔说可以。查尔斯说不行。不，我们谈过这个了。
And Michael's like, I'm sorry, this is my branch.
And I like your initiative, Kevin.
And yes.
And Charles just shuts him down.
He's like, that's not how we're going to do this.
And how does Michael respond?
Michael starts doing that, like...
Six-year-old thing.
迈克尔说，抱歉，这是我的分部。我喜欢你的主动性，凯文。是的。查尔斯直接拒绝了他。他说，我们不能那样做。迈克尔是怎么回应的？迈克尔开始做那种……六岁小孩做的事。
That echo thing where you just repeat what the other person is saying.
Yeah.
I know you are.
And then it's like going on and on, and everyone in the bullpen is saying, Michael, stop it.
Please.
Pam has a talking head where she says she can tell how upset Michael is by which comedy routine he uses and how infantile and immature he gets.
He has skipped over the Ace Ventura butt routine, which never happens.
那种回声游戏，你只是重复对方说的话。是的。我知道你是。我知道你是。然后它没完没了，牛棚里的每个人都在说，迈克尔，停下。求你了。帕姆有一个采访镜头，她说她能看出迈克尔有多沮丧，通过他使用的喜剧套路以及他变得多么幼稚和不成熟。他跳过了艾斯·文图拉的屁股套路，这从来没发生过。
She knows this is bad.
He skipped over Ace Ventura butt routine.
That's the talking butt.
Yeah, I know the talking butt.
I know it. He's going to take all that energy and he's going to say, all right, fine, party planning committee in the conference room. And there was a thing in the script where he was like, you guys just pitch me ideas because maybe planning my party will make me feel better.
I remember shooting this scene. We had a hard time getting through it. I bet. I bet. Well, while you guys start pitching party ideas, Charles is going to go over to Phyllis and say, you know, what is the PPC? And Phyllis says it's the party planning committee.
and they spend hours planning parties.
And then Phyllis would have had a talking head.
她知道这很糟糕。他跳过了艾斯·文图拉的屁股套路。那是会说话的屁股。是的，我知道那个会说话的屁股。我知道它。他要把所有的能量都用上，然后说，好吧，好吧，派对策划委员会到会议室来。剧本里有一段，他说，你们就给我提建议吧，因为也许策划我的派对会让我感觉好点。我记得拍摄这个场景。我们很难演完它。我敢打赌。我敢打赌。好吧，当你们开始提派对建议时，查尔斯要走到菲利斯身边说，你知道，什么是PPC？菲利斯说这是派对策划委员会。他们花几个小时策划派对。然后菲利斯原本会有一个采访镜头。
And I so wish it had made it in.
Are you ready for some Phyllis sass?
Here's her talking head.
I built that house.
I can burn it down.
Oh, I love this side of Phyllis,
especially when it's not directed at Angela.
Well, in that moment when Charles is talking to Phyllis,
我真希望它能保留下来。你准备好迎接菲利斯的傲慢了吗？这是她的采访镜头。那房子是我盖的。我可以把它烧掉。哦，我喜欢菲利斯的这一面，尤其是当它不是针对安吉拉的时候。好吧，在查尔斯和菲利斯交谈的那一刻，
at 14 minutes, 48 seconds, you get a real good shot
of this silver insulated coffee mug
that he's been carrying around all day.
Do you know what it said on it?
What?
Sattacoys Steel.
Oh, nice detail.
Way to go, Phil Shea.
在14分48秒，你有一个很好的镜头，拍到了他整天随身携带的那个银色保温咖啡杯。你知道上面写着什么吗？什么？萨塔科伊钢铁公司。哦，不错的细节。干得好，菲尔·谢。
Yeah.
Because when Charles enters the conference room,
he is holding that Satequois Steel coffee mug
eye level to Michael Scott.
And I don't know.
I just felt like it was subliminally pissing Michael off.
Just poking the bear.
Yeah, just rubbing it in his face.
是的。因为当查尔斯进入会议室时，他拿着那个萨塔科伊钢铁公司的咖啡杯，视线与迈克尔·斯科特平齐。我不知道。我只是觉得这在潜意识里激怒了迈克尔。就像在戳熊。是的，只是在他脸上摩擦。
Well, Charles wants to know what the heck they're doing in there. He now has been tipped off by Phyllis, that this is a big waste of time. And he starts to look over Jim's shoulder. And he's like, what is a two-way petting zoo? And Jim is really embarrassed. And he says, you pet the animals, they pet you back. We could not get through that. Two-way petting zoo did us in every time. I got a little bit curious.
You did not look up two-way petting zoo. I did. Oh, no. Is that a burning man? Because I have a friend who was in a petting zoo at Burrower.
Man. What? What is that? What is that? Okay. Someone I did improv with, and I'll never forget,
you know, she's kind of like a free spirit, and I was at the airport, this is years ago,
and I see her running through the airport, and it looked like she had, like, I don't know,
she had like a carry-on, but you could see sort of like a onesie poking out of it. She's running
through the airport. I'm like, hi, and she's like, hi. And she's like, so good to see you.
And I was like, you too.
好吧，查尔斯想知道他们在里面到底在干什么。他现在被菲利斯告密了，说这完全是在浪费时间。他开始越过吉姆的肩膀看。他说，什么是双向宠物动物园？吉姆非常尴尬。他说，你抚摸动物，它们也抚摸你。我们无法演完那个。双向宠物动物园每次都让我们笑场。我有点好奇。你没有查双向宠物动物园。我查了。哦，不。那是火人节吗？因为我有个朋友在火人节的宠物动物园里。什么？那是什么？那是什么？好吧。我和某人一起做即兴表演，我永远不会忘记，你知道，她有点像个自由灵魂，我在机场，那是几年前的事了，我看到她在机场跑，看起来她有，我不知道，她有一个随身行李，但你可以看到像连体衣一样的东西从里面露出来。她在机场跑。我说，嗨，她说，嗨。她说，见到你真好。我说，你也是。
She's like, where are you going?
I was like, I'm going to see my folks.
I said, what about you?
And she said, oh, I'm going to Burning Man.
I'm in the petting zoo this year.
And so I had to say, what, what, what's the petting zoo?
She was like, well, you know, you dress up as animals and let people pet you.
Wow.
她说，你要去哪儿？我说，我要去看我父母。我说，你呢？她说，哦，我要去火人节。我今年在宠物动物园。所以我不得不问，什么，什么，什么是宠物动物园？她说，嗯，你知道，你打扮成动物，让人们抚摸你。哇。
Yeah.
That's what I thought of when I, when you said that.
I, I did not know that.
I mean, I found out that there's no such thing as a two-way petting zoo where actual animals pet the humans,
but I did not know about this human petting zoo at Burning Man.
Did you think animals would pet humans?
You know what, lady, I didn't know.
是的。是的。这就是你刚才说的时候我想到的。我，我不知道那个。我的意思是，我发现根本没有所谓的双向宠物动物园，真正的动物会抚摸人类，但我不知道火人节上还有这种人类宠物动物园。你以为动物会抚摸人类吗？你知道吗，女士，我不知道。
I admit, it was a weird Google.
Yeah.
But I did find this.
What?
Two-way petting zoo is apparently like a euphemism for describing like a really intense, passionate sexual encounter.
or like you would be like, oh, me and my boyfriend had a real two-way petting zoo last night.
No, come on.
Who talks like that?
我承认，那是一个奇怪的谷歌搜索。是的。但我确实发现了这个。什么？双向宠物动物园显然是一个委婉语，用来描述那种非常激烈、充满激情的性接触。或者你会说，哦，我和我男朋友昨晚经历了一场真正的双向宠物动物园。不，得了吧。谁会那样说话？
But you are giving me flashbacks of like sixth grade sex ed.
We're like, we had a coach teach us sixth grade sex ed.
And he was like, sometimes there's heavy petting.
Sometimes we're like, ah.
Happy petting.
Heavy petting.
Yeah.
I don't know.
但你让我想起了六年级的性教育。我们有一个教练教我们六年级性教育。他说，有时会有激烈的爱抚。有时我们就像，啊。快乐的爱抚。激烈的爱抚。是的。我不知道。
Well, we don't know what Jim meant, but we know he's super embarrassed.
Well, Charles has had enough. He wants to dissolve the PPC, effective immediately.
This is where Michael completely flips out. And there was a deleted scene where he made a defensive
argument to keep the PPC. Oh, we need to hear it.
The party planning committee is an institution in this institution. It is something that I incorporated
in the mid-90s to celebrate the laser disc release of a league of their own. It has become a
tradition here. It is something that is important to all of us. What did we do for League of
Their Own party? Make your own pizza. I didn't even work here then. I just shared the stories.
好吧，我们不知道吉姆是什么意思，但我们知道他超级尴尬。好吧，查尔斯受够了。他想立即解散PPC。这就是迈克尔彻底崩溃的地方。有一个被删减的场景，他做了一个防御性的论点来保留PPC。哦，我们需要听听。派对策划委员会是这个机构里的一个机构。这是我在90年代中期为了庆祝《红粉联盟》的激光影碟发行而成立的。它已经成为这里的一个传统。这对我们所有人来说都很重要。我们为《红粉联盟》派对做了什么？自己做披萨。我那时甚至不在这里工作。我只是分享故事。
Okay. Thank you, Dwight. That should take five minutes of one person's day. Really? Five minutes.
Yeah. And then that's where the scene picks up. And he just goes off and he's like, you don't even know how paper is
made. It's not like steel, you don't put it in a furnace. And he starts like to cry. And he shoves over a chair.
On his way out.
That was not in the script.
He has a whole tantrum.
I remember.
After Michael leaves, Jim is going to attempt to start over with Charles.
好吧。谢谢，德怀特。那应该只需要一个人一天五分钟的时间。真的吗？五分钟。是的。然后场景就在那里接上了。他直接爆发了，他说，你甚至不知道纸是怎么造出来的。它不像钢铁，你不会把它放进熔炉里。他开始哭。他推倒了一把椅子。在他离开的路上。那不在剧本里。他发了一通脾气。我记得。迈克尔离开后，吉姆试图和查尔斯重新开始。
Yeah.
And this created...
Fenmel, Fenmel, Flurry!
Number two.
Oh.
A lot of people wrote in.
This is a quote.
I am so excited to finally get to discuss my biggest pet peeve in the whole series.
是的。这创造了……粉丝邮件，粉丝邮件，风暴！第二波。哦。很多人写信来。这是一句引语。我很高兴终于能讨论我在整个系列中最大的烦恼了。
Oh, my goodness.
What? At 16 minutes 40 seconds, Jim says he's a great number two for the office. And Charles responds by saying he didn't know that position existed. And then Jim kind of like tap dances and he's like, well, at first it was made up for Dwight, but then, you know, Michael gave it to me. And kind of all ends with Charles being like, is this made up position important to you? Yeah. Well, people are P-O'd.
At who? Here's the thing. I mean, people sent in lists of evidence to say that this number two position that Jim holds is real. It is not a made-up position and that Charles should know that. Here's the evidence. In branch closing, Jan is talking to Jim about going back to Scranton and she says, quote, we'd like to offer you the number two position at that branch. In the merger, Michael is on the phone with Jan after firing Tony.
he tries to blame Dwight by saying bad advice from my number two, and Jan says,
Jim is your number two.
I sent you a memo about this.
In the merger, Jim confirms to Dwight that the job comes with a pay raise.
Oh, yeah.
哦，天哪。什么？在16分40秒，吉姆说他是办公室里很棒的二把手。查尔斯回应说他不知道那个职位存在。然后吉姆有点像踢踏舞一样，他说，嗯，起初它是为德怀特编造的，但后来，你知道，迈克尔把它给了我。最后查尔斯说，这个编造的职位对你很重要吗？是的。好吧，人们很生气。对谁？事情是这样的。我的意思是，人们寄来了证据清单，说吉姆持有的这个二把手职位是真实的。这不是一个编造的职位，查尔斯应该知道这一点。这是证据。在分部关闭中，简和吉姆谈论回到斯克兰顿，她说，引用，我们想提供给你那个分部的二把手职位。在合并中，迈克尔在解雇托尼后和简通电话，他试图通过说我的二把手给的坏建议来责怪德怀特，简说，吉姆是你的二把手。我给你发过关于这个的备忘录。在合并中，吉姆向德怀特确认这份工作带有加薪。哦，是的。
In Benihanna Christmas, when Pam gives her Christmas gift to Jim, he turns it down,
using, quote, his promotion as an excuse.
Also in a Benihana Christmas, Dwight refers to him,
as the ranking number three, and he finally concedes to Jim's authority as ranking number two,
this is when, you know, they're trying to validate the committee to plan parties.
Right.
They get in this whole argument.
In the return, Andy tells Jim, I'm thrilled to be working directly beneath you.
在《本尼哈纳圣诞节》中，当帕姆给吉姆圣诞礼物时，他拒绝了，用，引用，他的晋升作为借口。同样在《本尼哈纳圣诞节》中，德怀特称他为排名第三，他最终承认了吉姆作为排名第二的权威，这是当，你知道，他们试图验证策划派对的委员会时。对。他们陷入了整个争论。在《回归》中，安迪告诉吉姆，我很激动能直接在你手下工作。
And in women's appreciation, Dwight tells Jim, you may be second in command, but that does not put you above the law.
This is a real position.
I agree with everybody that, yes.
I think Jim doesn't present it well, and then he gets flustered.
I think so too.
By the way, great research, everyone.
Yeah.
I'm very impressed.
在《女性欣赏》中，德怀特告诉吉姆，你可能是二把手，但这并不让你凌驾于法律之上。这是一个真实的职位。我同意大家的看法，是的。我觉得吉姆表现得不好，然后他变得慌乱了。我也这么认为。顺便说一下，大家的研究做得很好。是的。我印象非常深刻。
Let me give a shout out to Laura Kay, Alexandra Kay, Cy L, Dan C., Emily M, and others.
Well done.
I like it.
People were fired up.
It was a fan mail blizzard.
Yeah.
Jim just can't win with Charles.
让我向劳拉·凯、亚历山德拉·凯、赛·L、丹·C、艾米丽·M等人致敬。干得好。我喜欢它。人们很兴奋。我喜欢它。这是一场粉丝邮件暴风雪。是的。吉姆就是无法赢得查尔斯的认可。
There were more scenes where he just got busted throughout the day.
One of them happened at front reception.
Oh, I remember shooting this.
Can we hear that?
He really doesn't like me.
But you look so dapper.
Thank you.
I'm working so hard.
还有更多的场景，他整天都被训斥。其中一个发生在接待处。哦，我记得拍摄这个。我们能听听吗？他真的不喜欢我。但你看起来很帅。谢谢。我工作很努力。
I was hitting the phones.
I closed the sale.
I updated my contact.
What?
Hey, go tell him you updated your contact list.
I would tell him if you're mocking me.
Really?
Today.
我一直在打电话。我完成了销售。我更新了我的联系人。什么？嘿，去告诉他你更新了你的联系人列表。如果你在嘲笑我，我会告诉他的。真的吗？今天。
Like, I don't know I'm enough going.
on. I'm sorry. Have a candy. Thank you. Sweetie, do you mind anything that at your desk? I don't want
him to keep seeing us together. Okay, when I had to say that line, could you eat that at your desk?
We could not get through that. That made John and I laugh so hard that Pam was like, could you,
could you just do that somewhere else? He also, which you guys can't see it, right? It's in the deleted
scenes if you have the DVDs. When Pam says that, John is Jim, looks at the camera, like super
deadpan. Like, are you kidding me? I remember all of that. I remember it so clearly.
Well, Michael's going to drive to corporate. He's going to confront David Wallace as he's
就像，我不知道我还有多少事情要做。抱歉。吃颗糖吧。谢谢。亲爱的，你介意在你的办公桌上吃那个吗？我不想让他一直看到我们在一起。好吧，当我不得不说那句台词时，你能在那张桌子上吃那个吗？我们无法演完那个。那让约翰和我笑得太厉害了，帕姆说，你能，你能去别的地方做那个吗？他还，你们看不到，对吧？如果你有DVD，它在被删减的场景里。当帕姆那样说时，约翰饰演的吉姆，看着摄像机，超级面无表情。就像，你在开玩笑吗？我记得所有这些。我记得非常清楚。好吧，迈克尔要开车去总公司。他要在大卫·华莱士离开男洗手间时与他对质。
leaving the men's room. This is a classic Michael move. I'm sorry, you guys, but Angela did that
to me today. I did. I went to the restroom during our break. Okay, first of all, there's only one
bathroom here. And one hallway. Yeah. But you were right there.
And you had this email you wanted to show me.
So as soon as she came out of the bathroom, I was like, look at this.
And I said, you just Michael Scott at me.
Yeah.
Anyway, David Wallace, here's Michael out.
这是经典的迈克尔动作。抱歉，伙计们，但安吉拉今天对我做了这件事。我做了。我们在休息时去了洗手间。好吧，首先，这里只有一个洗手间。还有一个走廊。是的。但你就在那里。你有一封邮件想给我看。所以当她从洗手间出来时，我就说，看这个。我说，你刚才对我迈克尔·斯科特了。是的。总之，大卫·华莱士听了迈克尔的诉求。
And he's like, you know what?
Look, you can have your 15th anniversary party.
You can have the figs.
Michael keeps talking about these figs.
I know.
There was a whole fig runner.
What?
Yes, in the script.
他说，你知道吗？看，你可以举办你的15周年纪念派对。你可以有无花果。迈克尔一直在谈论这些无花果。我知道。有一个完整的无花果梗。什么？是的，在剧本里。
I thought this was like just like a random thing.
And I was so tickled by it.
I was like, what is his commitment to having figs?
Yeah.
So this would have been a callback to an earlier scene.
When they're doing all the party planning, one of the things Michael wanted was like bacon-wrapped figs.
Okay?
And then remember when he started to spiral out to Charles Minor about canceling the party?
我以为这只是一个随机的事情。我被它逗乐了。我说，他对拥有无花果的执着是什么？是的。所以这原本是对之前场景的回应。当他们做所有的派对策划时，迈克尔想要的东西之一就是培根裹无花果。好吗？然后记得当他开始对查尔斯·迈纳失控取消派对时吗？
He had this whole speech where he was like, there will be horse-drawn carriages, there will be penchetta-wrapped figs, there will be break dancers.
Wow.
Yeah.
Those are the figs.
The figs.
They've already arrived.
They're arrived.
What's he going to do with them?
他有整段演讲，他说会有马车，会有意式培根裹无花果，会有霹雳舞者。哇。是的。那些就是无花果。无花果。它们已经到了。它们到了。他要拿它们怎么办？
Exactly.
So David Wallace says, I will come to your party.
You can have your figs.
I will move some money around.
Yeah.
And make it happen.
But Michael says, he smiles and you think he's happy.
And then he says, I quit.
完全正确。所以大卫·华莱士说，我会参加你的派对。你可以有你的无花果。我会挪动一些钱。是的。让它发生。但迈克尔说，他笑了，你以为他很高兴。然后他说，我不干了。
Mm-hmm.
He quits.
I was so surprised.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
I have a real tangent.
to throw in here.
Okay.
嗯哼。他辞职了。我太惊讶了。太棒了。是的。我有一个真正的题外话要在这里插入。好吧。
I don't know if you noticed, but at the very beginning of the scene, David Wallace is drinking
water out of a Fiji water bottle.
It was really random to me because he's turned the bottle in such a way that you can't see
the name facing you, but it's clearly Fiji water.
And I was so confused because I thought they never let us do that.
No.
And I just wondered, was that he had been drinking some Fiji water and ended up in the scene
and he turned, because, you know, was he, I don't know.
我不知道你有没有注意到，在场景的最开始，大卫·华莱士正在用斐济水瓶喝水。这对我来说真的很随机，因为他把瓶子转成这样，你看不见名字对着你，但很明显是斐济水。我非常困惑，因为我以为他们从不让我们那样做。没有。我只是想知道，是他一直在喝斐济水，最后出现在场景里，他转了过来，因为，你知道，他是，我不知道。
I just, it stood out to me.
But it also stood out to me because earlier in the week, by coincidence, my family became
fascinated with the origins of bottled water.
So we're in this phase right now.
We're our 10-year-old.
If we're talking at dinner and we bring up something, he wants to look it up and find out
everything about it.
I wonder where he gets that.
我只是，它对我来说很突出。但它也让我印象深刻，因为在本周早些时候，巧合的是，我的家人对瓶装水的起源着迷了。所以我们现在处于这个阶段。我们的10岁孩子。如果我们在晚餐时谈话，我们提到了什么，他想查一下并找出关于它的一切。我想知道他从哪儿学来的。
Well, we were discussing getting new water bottles for school, you know, the reusable one.
and this got us on bottled water, and my son ended up doing a whole deep dive for our family
on the origins of bottled water, and I thought I would share a little bit about it, since what the
coincidence that David Wallace is holding a water bottle? Okay. This is my son's deep dive,
and I find it fascinating, and I think you will too, even though you're not as mother.
The first commercially distributed bottled water company in America was called Jackson Spa.
and it was founded in 1767 in Boston.
This was the question that launched everything was,
好吧，我们正在讨论为学校买新的水瓶，你知道，可重复使用的那种。这让我们谈到了瓶装水，我儿子最终为我们全家做了一个关于瓶装水起源的深度挖掘，我想分享一点，因为大卫·华莱士拿着水瓶是多么巧合？好吧。这是我儿子的深度挖掘，我觉得它很迷人，我想你也会觉得，即使你不是母亲。美国第一家商业分销的瓶装水公司叫杰克逊温泉。它成立于1767年的波士顿。这就是启动一切的问题，
who made the first bottle of water.
It was Jackson Spa,
and the people who drank the water
thought that it held therapeutic properties
because it came from like one of those mineral springs,
a natural spring.
One of the biggies, Arrowhead, was established in 1917.
That's so early.
谁制造了第一瓶水。是杰克逊温泉，喝水的人认为它具有治疗功效，因为它来自那些矿泉之一，天然泉水。大人物之一，箭牌，成立于1917年。那太早了。
I know.
Arrowhead water is sourced from the mountain springs
in California, Colorado, and Canada.
It's bottled in California, even today.
Then we get up to Evian.
That was not established until 1978,
almost 70 years after Arrowhead.
Their water comes from a spring in the French Alps.
我知道。箭牌水来自加利福尼亚、科罗拉多和加拿大的山泉。即使在今天，它也是在加利福尼亚装瓶的。然后我们到了依云。那直到1978年才成立，比箭牌晚了近70年。他们的水来自法国阿尔卑斯山的一个泉水。
Fiji water, as held by David Wallace,
comes from Fiji.
But the big shift in bottled water came
when Pepsi and Coca-Cola got into the game
by selling purified water.
Purified water.
is basically municipal tap water, which is then filtered using a process called reverse osmosis.
Spring water is also filtered, but the reverse osmosis is what purifies it, I guess.
大卫·华莱士拿着的斐济水，来自斐济。但瓶装水的重大转变发生在百事可乐和可口可乐通过销售纯净水进入游戏时。纯净水。基本上是市政自来水，然后使用一种叫做反渗透的过程进行过滤。泉水也被过滤，但反渗透是净化它的东西，我想。
That's the purified part.
Then we all wondered as a family, what's the best water?
Purified, spring, tap.
You know what it is?
Guess.
Tap.
Nope.
Spring.
那是纯净的部分。然后我们全家都想知道，什么是最好的水？纯净水、泉水、自来水。你知道是什么吗？猜猜。自来水。不。泉水。
Nope.
Purified.
Yes.
Purified water.
The reverse osmosis makes it the most pure above filtered spring or tap.
How about that?
Pepsi and Coke were already using purified water as the basis of their sodas.
So they would get water, they would purify it, and then they would add all the bubbles,
不。纯净水。是的。纯净水。反渗透使它成为最纯净的水，超过了过滤泉水或自来水。怎么样？百事可乐和可口可乐已经在使用纯净水作为他们苏打水的基础。所以他们会得到水，他们会净化它，然后他们会加入所有的气泡，
and then they would add all the other stuff that you put in a soda.
Yeah.
And so it was really easy for them to just start bottling it before they did all the rest of it.
to make it a soda.
Well, I think that's a fascinating deep dive.
Well done.
We are trying as a family to cut down on plastic.
It's super hard, you know?
然后他们会加入你在苏打水中添加的所有其他成分。是的。所以对他们来说，在做其他工序把它变成苏打水之前，直接开始装瓶真的很容易。嗯，我觉得这是一个非常引人入胜的深度解析。做得好。我们作为一个家庭正在努力减少塑料的使用。这真的超级难，你知道吗？
There's so much.
There's so much single-use plastic.
That's right.
And that's what we're trying to avoid.
Exactly.
And my husband just worked with this company that I find fascinating called Tetrapak.
Oh my gosh.
I watched his video that he made for them.
有太多了。一次性塑料实在太多了。没错。而这正是我们试图避免的。完全正确。我丈夫刚和一家我觉得很迷人的公司合作，叫利乐包（Tetrapak）。天哪。我看了他为他们制作的视频。
I know.
And it was great.
It was amazing.
They're putting water in everything you can imagine, soup.
And it just, if you start to notice what TetraPack looks like,
it's like paper packaging.
Yeah.
And the only thing that's plastic and it's like recycled plastic is the lid.
我知道。那太棒了。太神奇了。他们把水装进你能想象到的任何东西里，比如汤。如果你开始注意利乐包的样子，它就像纸包装。是的。唯一塑料的部分，而且是可回收塑料，就是盖子。
Yeah, it's the thing that like broth comes in.
Yes.
But coconut waters I see.
Box milk.
Yep.
Fascinating.
Another factory that I want to go to.
Oh, let's go to the factory.
是的，就是那种装肉汤的包装。没错。但我还看到过椰子水。盒装牛奶。是的。太迷人了。这是另一个我想参观的工厂。哦，我们去工厂吧。
I know.
Okay.
Well, back in our episode.
Charles is going to leave for the day.
He says goodbye.
Angela runs over to say goodbye.
and I loved the scene between Kelly and Phyllis in the kitchen.
Kelly's putting on lipstick.
我知道。好吧，回到我们的剧集。查尔斯要下班离开了。他说再见。安吉拉跑过去说再见。我很喜欢凯利和菲利斯在厨房里的那场戏。凯利正在涂口红。
She's like, I'm going to make them buy me a steak tonight.
And Phyllis is like, first of all, I'm the only person here.
Because she starts with you guys.
I know, I know.
And then she's like, I think he already left.
And Mindy as Kelly goes barreling out, kind of knocks into camera.
Do you see her start to break?
Yes, I wrote it down.
她说：我今晚要让他们给我买牛排。菲利斯说：首先，这里只有我一个人。因为她一开始是对你们说的。我知道，我知道。然后她说：我想他已经走了。当明迪饰演的凯利冲出去时，撞到了摄像机。你看到她开始笑场了吗？是的，我记下来了。
She started to laugh as she pushed through the door.
I also want to say, Phyllis is drinking coffee at the very end of the day.
Needs pick me up.
Just a little thing to note.
Afternoon pick me up.
Kelly bolts out to the parking lot and Angela is out there holding Charles's scarf.
In the rain.
She swiped it 100%.
她在穿过门的时候开始笑了。我还想说，菲利斯在一天结束时在喝咖啡。需要提神。只是一个小细节。下午提神。凯利冲向停车场，安吉拉在那里拿着查尔斯的围巾。在雨中。她百分之百是偷来的。
She swiped that scarf.
She quietly plots, okay?
Kelly is very out there with what her plans are, but Angela was secretly plotting.
Shooting the scene was so much fun.
It was actually raining.
We had to time it out so that, you know, Mindy would come running out and I would come around the
corner and we would see each other and then start yelling our scene at each other. And then they were like,
we want you to chase after her and you run. So we like took off. I loved every second of doing these
她偷了那条围巾。她悄悄地策划，好吗？凯利对她的计划非常直白，但安吉拉是在秘密策划。拍摄那场戏太有趣了。当时真的在下雨。我们必须掌握好时间，你知道，明迪跑出来，我从拐角处过来，我们看到彼此，然后开始对着对方大喊我们的台词。然后他们说：我们想要你追着她跑。所以我们就跑开了。我喜欢拍摄这些与明迪对手戏的每一秒。
scenes with Mindy. You guys had to run in your heels. In our heels. On the wet pavement. I also remember
talking to Paul Feig about, wait, how would Angela Martin run in this moment? You know? Oh, how does your
character run? Yeah. And I had done fun run, but she was a
angry running, right, about sprinkles. But this was like, I had heels and how would Angela Martin
run? And these are small details, but they're so fun to like figure out. But this is what you do
as an actor. You make these choices for how your character would do something that's different
from how you would do it. Yeah. And then after this, I have this talking head. And then I have a
talking head, but we did not film my talking head that day. So they had to try to match how wet my
你们得穿着高跟鞋跑。穿着高跟鞋。在湿漉漉的人行道上。我还记得和保罗·费格讨论，等等，安吉拉·马丁在这时候会怎么跑？你知道吗？哦，你的角色怎么跑？是的。我拍过“趣味跑”，但那是为了斯普林克尔斯而愤怒地跑，对吧？但这次我有高跟鞋，安吉拉·马丁会怎么跑？这些都是小细节，但弄清楚它们非常有趣。这就是作为演员你要做的事。你要为你的角色做出选择，决定她如何做某事，这与你自己的做法不同。是的。在这之后，我有一个采访镜头。我有一个采访镜头，但我们那天没有拍摄我的采访镜头。所以他们必须尝试匹配我头发看起来有多湿。
hair would have looked. They spritz my hair with water.
They put water on my face, let my mascara run down my cheeks.
And then I had to deliver this monologue as if I had just run away from Kelly.
So I was like winded.
Now let me ask you, before you started shooting, did you stand up and like do like a fake run?
Because I've done that before when I have to enter out of breath.
I'll do like a little jog in place.
I did not.
他们往我的头发上喷水。他们在我的脸上洒水，让睫毛膏顺着脸颊流下来。然后我必须表现出好像我刚从凯利那里跑开一样来完成这段独白。所以我气喘吁吁的。现在让我问你，在开始拍摄之前，你有没有站起来做那种假跑？因为我以前必须表现出气喘吁吁地出场时做过。我会原地小跑一下。我没有。
Oh.
That's all that's all fake.
You didn't need it.
I didn't need it.
I just did this.
Kelly and Charles, absolutely not.
He is a sophisticated man.
He doesn't need to go dumpster diving for companionship, okay?
哦。那全是假的。你不需要它。我不需要。我只是做了这个。凯利和查尔斯，绝对不可能。他是一个成熟的男人。他不需要为了陪伴去翻垃圾桶，好吗？
Wow.
Thank you.
That's really good.
Well, listen, that is new boss, but Angela, there would have been something here.
Those driving scenes.
Yes, Michael driving away from his meeting with David Wallace.
哇。谢谢。那真的很好。谢谢。那真的很好。好吧，听着，那是“新老板”，但安吉拉，这里本来会有一些东西的。那些开车场景。是的，迈克尔从和大卫·华莱士的会议中开车离开。
They're so funny.
I read in the shooting draft, there were so many.
They just let Michael go on and on and on.
Well, here's a few I want you to hear that made Delioux.
deleted scenes.
Wow!
Oh boy!
Like Thelma and Louise driving off the cliff.
它们太搞笑了。我在拍摄草稿里读到过，有很多。他们只是让迈克尔不停地说啊说。好吧，这里有几个我想让你听听的被删减的片段。哇！天哪！就像《末路狂花》开车冲下悬崖一样。
I'm really not even sure what just happened.
I went inside and...
That was real, right?
No, Mom, I don't know if I did the right thing.
It's just...
It's just what I did, okay?
Don't put Jeff on the phone.
I don't...
我真的甚至不确定刚才发生了什么。我进去了，然后……那是真的，对吧？不，妈妈，我不知道我是否做了正确的事。这只是……这只是我所做的，好吗？别让杰夫接电话。我没有……
Please, I don't want to...
Hello, sir.
How are your trains?
There were a series like, where you're...
series like where he's sort of talking to himself like I can't believe this happened. Then he calls,
right? Then he's laughing hysterically. Then he's eating pizza. Then he's crying. They just went on and
on. But I loved that his mom put Jeff on the phone. What's up with Jeff in trains?
Is there something where he talks about Jeff collecting trains at some point in an earlier episode?
求你了，我不想……你好，先生。你的火车怎么样了？有一系列这样的场景，他有点自言自语，比如我不敢相信发生了这种事。然后他打电话，对吧？然后他歇斯底里地大笑。然后他在吃披萨。然后他在哭。他们只是没完没了。但我喜欢他妈妈让杰夫接电话。杰夫和火车是怎么回事？在之前的某一集中，他有没有提到过杰夫收集火车？
I feel like maybe. Maybe. But that would have been the tag. It would have been Michael in the car,
leaving New York and all these series of emotions and little snippets in his car.
Well, this whole thing is going to lead to one of my personal favorite storylines of the
entire series for my character of Pam. And that is when Michael starts his own paper company and
Pam goes with him. I can't wait to watch these episodes. I can't wait. All right, you guys,
that was New Boss. We hope you're having a great week and we'll be here next week. See you then.
Bye.
for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
我觉得可能有。也许吧。但这本来会是片尾彩蛋。本来会是迈克尔在车里，离开纽约，车里有一系列的情绪和片段。好吧，整件事将引出我个人在整部剧中为帕姆这个角色最喜欢的故事情节之一。那就是迈克尔创办自己的造纸公司，帕姆和他一起去。我迫不及待想看这些剧集了。我迫不及待了。好了，各位，这就是“新老板”。我们希望你们度过了愉快的一周，我们下周会在这里。到时候见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。
This episode was initially created
in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey
and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent.
Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。